Alles oder nichts gilt es jetzt für die drei Kandidaten. Es geht um die alles entscheidende dritte Runde. Bieten wir die grünen Gewinnplatte an. 5000 Mark ist jetzt der Höchstbetrag und ein Rätsel aus dem Bereich Redewinnung geht immer an. Gut, ohne Helmen, ohne Gurt. 5000 wollen wir jetzt als nächsten Betrag sehen. Könnte vielleicht klappen.
Ein SP Siegfried. SP Siegfried.
Ein R wie Richard. Eine Stimmung ist hier, wenn Bayern München das lange Willen mal vorschießt, wo eine Stimmung herstirbt. Und erneut bahnt sich hier der Höchstbetreiber in der Hand. Ein N wie Nordpol. N wie Nordpol. 55.750 DM. Du hast tot auf dem Kontor. Und dann möchte ich lösen? Dann wollt sie lösen. Einen Ratten-Schwanz hinter sich herziehen. Und gesteinert!
Kann ich auch ein Ketergramm haben.
Da fragt sich, was die anderen beiden Bereiche noch sind, die da noch mit einbauten.
Mühleimer und...
Ja, und dann gibt es diese Küchenberater bei IKEA, die, glaube ich, irgendwie auch alles schon gesehen haben. Ich meine, ich weiß nicht, wie es euch so geht, große Unternehmen. Ich meine, wer geht zum Media-Markt, zum Berater? Bist du immer froh, wenn du mit diesen Leuten nichts zu tun haben musst, weil du eh nicht davon ausgehst, dass sie dir irgendwie helfen können. Aber ich war so ein, zwei Mal bei der ganzen Küchenplanung an so einem Punkt angelangt, wo es einfach alles nicht gepasst hat. Ich wusste einfach nicht, wie ich es arrangieren soll, dass es irgendwie passt.
Das ging eigentlich.
Ja, das hängt aber immer von der Küchensituation ab.
Schlimm ist dieser IKEA-Küchenplaner, dieses Plug-in, was man da runterladen muss und in seinem Browser laufen lassen muss. Und was so unglaublich langsam ist, also zumindest auf Mac, unter Windows scheint es halbwegs zu funktionieren. Und du irgendwie immer Sekunden darauf wartest, dass er jetzt irgendwie die Küche um fünf Grad gedreht hat in der 3D-Ansicht und so weiter. Und dann willst du irgendwas platzieren und dann mach das sonst wo und dann mach das woanders hin. Und dann steht der Schrank plötzlich an einer anderen Wand. Und so, also das war ein bisschen gruselig.
Das hab ich nicht benutzt, aber ich hab diese Leute benutzt. Ich hab denen immer so meine Probleme geschildert. Und das ist geil, man erkennt das ja sicherlich auch vom Programmieren. Es hilft ja immer schon, seine Probleme nicht immer zu schildern. Groß anguckt und während man es erklärt hat, hat man es verstanden. Das war so der eine Effekt, aber der andere ist, dass ihr eben auch so bestimmte Annahmen, die man so manchmal auch mit sich herumträgt, einfach aus dem Hirn raushaut. Also zum Beispiel, ich kam irgendwie nicht klar mit, wo Ofen und meine Platte und so weiter, hab ihr so meine Pläne gezeigt, ich dachte, das passt irgendwie alles gar nicht zusammen. Und dann fragte sie mich so, ja, ob denn der Ofen unbedingt unter der Herdplatte sein muss. Und weißt du, da hab ich irgendwie vorher nie drüber nachgedacht, weil man ist so von alten...
Ich hab das automatisch daneben gemacht.
Von alten Küchen, da hat man das irgendwie noch so drin, dass so das Kochfeld und der Ofen irgendwie ein Item ist. Deswegen tut man das automatisch da drunter. Aber es ist natürlich sowieso viel praktischer, wenn du Schubladen da drunter hast. Weil dann kannst du das ganze Gerät, was du so brauchst, Töpfe, Bratenwänder, Klimbim und so weiter, Gewürze, alles, was du immer am Kochfeld brauchst, kannst du natürlich viel besser da mit Schubladen machen. Schubladen da drunter gemacht, den Ofen woanders hingemacht, alles hat gepasst. Das waren einfach solche Hirnbefreier. Ich fand diese ganze Phase unglaublich aufregend. Ich möchte unbedingt noch mal eine Küche bauen. Ja, noch wie geil das ist.
Ich will erst mal einen Induktionsherrn.
Und dann mach ich den Dusseanzug von unten. Wir hatten das in diesem komischen IKEA-Küchenplaner vorgeplant und sind dann dahin marschiert. Und dann hat der Typ sich das so anguckt, so, ja, so, ja, ich zeig ihn mal, wenn sie das so machen. Hat er das wieder weggemacht. Und da könnten sie noch das machen. Hat er das wieder weggemacht. Und dann hat er das so im Prinzip so. So, und dann, und dann der Fehler. Bestellt als Zentrallagerlieferung. Also alle, die jetzt zuhören und sich demnächst von IKEA meinen, irgendwie eine Küche liefern zu lassen. Nicht als Zentrallagerlieferung. Weil nämlich, diese dämliche Zentrallagerlieferung, die haben es nicht drauf, Teillieferungen zu machen.
Das heißt, entweder das ist alles oder gar nichts.
Du vereinbarst einen Termin und dann weisen sie dich schon darauf hin, dass das nur ein vorläufiger Termin ist und dass das eventuell sich noch verschiebt, aber eigentlich nicht. Und dann verschiebt er sich natürlich doch, weil irgendein verdammtes Teil nicht da ist. Die Vorderseite von der Schublade oder irgendwas total Unwichtiges.
Da sind sie wieder, die lemon-soaked-Papern.
Irgendetwas total Unwichtiges, weil dieser Köche ist nicht da. Und dann schicken die die Lieferung nicht los. Und mich haben sie halt drei Tage vorher angerufen, ne, das wird nichts. Und dann hab ich da irgendwie fürchterlich Ärger gemacht. Und dann meinte die Frau so, na ja, dann nehm ich jetzt die Teile raus aus der Lieferung, die nicht lieferbar sind. Ja, und dann müsste das am Montag, also am Dienstag sollten sie sie dann liefern, dann müssten die das am Montag, am Samstag haben sie mich angerufen, dass es nix wird, Samstagabend, dass es nix wird. Ja, dann müsste es am Montag durchgehen. Aber rufen sie lieber noch mal an. Und dann ruf ich natürlich Montag noch mal an. Ja nee, wir liefern die in zwei Wochen. Wie? Da wollten wir schon eingezogen sein. Das geht nicht. Fürchterlich einen Rabatz gemacht. Und was die eigentliche Lösung ist, man geht dann doch ins Möbelhaus. Weil im Möbelhaus haben sie entweder alles da, oder sie sagen einem, ja, was weiß ich, die Schubladenfront ist halt nicht da. Und wenn du dann die Küche schon fertig geplant hast, alles, was der machte, ist dann, der klickt dann so, ne, die ganze Lieferung, okay, Copy and Paste, neuer Auftrag, schicken wir ihn, geht morgen raus.
So.
Aufregend. Also Zentralagerlieferung bringt es gar nicht. Gleich am Möbelhaus bestellen, sonst von dort aus losschicken, das funktioniert dann auch. Und die machen auch Teillieferung. Also, ah, ne, da hab ich mich echt aufgeregt, weil das war, äh, naja.
Alle beschweren sich hier schon im Chat, warum wir uns denn über Küchen unterhalten, und nicht über die Apple Watch. Aber jetzt kommt der Spin.
Er hat hier auch eine Option.
Ich hab das Ladekabel schon. Ich hab ja noch ein extra Ladekabel dazu bestellt.
Das ist schon da.
Bei IKEA gibt es jetzt auch Ladeschalen. Du kannst jetzt in die Möbel auch so Ladeorte einbauen. Also Induktionskochplatte, sondern auch Induktionsladeplatte. Für die Apple Watch.
Geht mit der Apple Watch zusammen. Ist das das gleiche?
Das ist der selbe Standard. Das ist dieser Qi-Standard, Qi-Standard. Zumindest habe ich Berichte gelesen, wo Leute ihre Apple Watch mit Qi-Kram geladen haben, was nicht das offizielle Ladekabel ist, als auch mit dem offiziellen Ladekabel andere Geräte geladen haben, die nach diesem Qi-Standard sind. Apple scheint sich da an einem Standard zu.
Haben. Und dann wird die Apple Watch von der von unten saugenden Sauganlage direkt vom Inuktionsherd gesaugt.
Aber diese Lade-Dinger, müssen die dauerhaft an sein? Oder wie funktioniert das? Also, brauchen die dauerhaft Strom?
Die merken wahrscheinlich schon, dass da was drauf liegt.
Ja, warum das zu merken, müssen die auch schon die ganze Zeit an sein, oder?
Abteilung, dünnes Eis.
Da sind wir ja gerne unterwegs.
Da sind wir ja gerne unterwegs, aber wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, wenn da nichts zum Induzieren da drauf ist, dann fließt da auch kein Strom.
Ja, aber um es zu erkennen, muss ja doch was fließen, ne?
Ja, dünnes Eis.
Das ist immer eine Frage der Effektivität. Das ist wie so ein Steckernetzteil, das verlagert auch Strom.
Also wenn da was drauf liegt, dann ändert sich ja das Magnetfeld. Also irgendwas muss natürlich da sein, um das zu erkennen, aber das ist bestimmt total minimal. Ein Hauch von einem Strömchen.
Naja, aber ich meine, wenn das halt das ganze Jahr lang an ist, dann macht so was irgendwie auch schon.
Keine Ahnung, ich hab mit Wireless Charging, ehrlich gesagt, auch keine nennenswerten Erfahrungen. Also gar keine, um genau zu sein.
Ja, weil wir alle immer nur diese Apple Sachen benutzen, die voll lange halten und so.
Also meine Zahnbürste, Charged Wireless.
Stimmt, meine auch.
Hattet ihr denn die Watch, wir sind jetzt mal bei der Watch. Habt ihr denn die überhaupt schon in meiner Hand gehabt?
Nein.
Ich war mit Umziehen beschäftigt. Ich hatte diverse Dinge in der Hand in letzter Zeit, aber eine Uhr war nicht dabei.
Schon gar nicht von Apple? Ernsthaft, ich bin der Einzige, der sie überhaupt schon in meiner Hand hatte? Nein, ich hatte sie sogar schon am Arm.
Und, hat sie dir dein Herrchen gezupft?
Nee, ich hab nichts gezupft, aber ich hatte jetzt auch kein Link-Bracelet an. Ich hab mir gleich zu Beginn so einen Try-On-Termin geklickt. Zu meiner größten Überraschung war das auch gar kein Problem. Das kann daran gelegen haben, dass ich da in der Diaspora bin. In Bristol, da gibt es zwar einen Apple-Laden, also sogar zwei, aber...
Keine Leute, die Apple kennen.
Keine Leute, die sowas leisten könnten.
Keine Ahnung. Also auf jeden Fall hatten sie auch noch eine Woche später nach offizieller Verfügbarkeit kein MacBook da. Aber sie hatten halt die Uhren da liegen, also in diesem komischen Tisch da unter Glas und natürlich dann diese komischen Try-Ons. Die sind ja dann so eingespannt in so umgebaute iPads. Habt ihr vielleicht gesehen, die Fotos?
Ja, mit eigener Produktnummer und irgendwie FTC-Dings und sogar mit MagSafe-Anschluss.
Genau, so eine weiße Box, wo die Uhr halt so eingeklemmt ist und da dauerhaft geladen wird. Es gibt ja diesen Diagnostik-Port an dieser Apple Watch, also wenn man das eine Band abmacht.
Kann man das Türchen aufmachen?
Kann man das Türchen aufmachen und da gibt es dann so sechs Kontakte, glaube ich.
Der Hackerzugang.
Hackerzugang, genau. Keiner weiß bisher, also ich habe zumindest noch nichts gesehen, was es sei. Also ob es nun Lightning ist oder ob es vielleicht USB-C ist. Nobody knows. Ich schätze mal, eins von den beiden wird es sein. Nee, das glaube ich nicht. Ich schätze mal, das wird schon so ein vollwertiger Port sein. Aber ob es jetzt Lightning ist oder ob es, ich weiß nicht, was ihr vermuten würdet, ich würde sagen...
Wenn es Lightning ist, bräuchten sie es nicht so doll verstecken, oder?
Na, sie verstecken es... Weiß nicht, es ist halt jetzt noch kein Feature dieser Uhr. In der ersten Generation ist halt dieser Port so noch nicht da. Wahrscheinlich wollen sie das erstmal noch testen. Über kurz oder lang macht es natürlich total Sinn, diesen Port in dem Ding drin zu haben. Weil dann könntest du halt Bänder ranmachen, die sowohl Akku-Erweiterung darstellen. Oder du kannst halt auch GPS im Band haben.
Ja, aber wenn das Ding eh nur mit Telefon funktioniert, hast du es doch mit Telefon.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass das unbedingt ein Telefon braucht, um zu funktionieren.
Du meinst, es kann mir die Uhrzeit auch ohne Telefon anzeigen?
Allerdings!
Hab ich gehört! Das ist der Hammer! Also wirklich amazing! Theoretisch kannst du es ja auch als Sport-Uhr benutzen. Also wenn du Fitness-Kram machst, durch die Gegend läufst, dann ist die Uhr in der Lage, dein Herz, dein Puls sozusagen, dein Heart-Rate zu messen, als auch Schritte, halt Accelerometer, dieser ganze Glimp, nur halt kein Geomapping zu machen. Was ich persönlich eigentlich sehr reizvoll finde und deswegen immer noch ein Telefon mitnehmen würde. Das Problem hat, dass man halt noch ein Telefon mitnehmen muss, was irgendwie groß ist, was dann auch viel Strom verbraucht in dem Zusammenhang etc. pp. Und es wäre halt eigentlich ganz schön, wenn so eine Uhr ausreichen würde und aber trotzdem noch aufzeichnen würde, wo man denn jetzt gerade ist. Ich finde das irgendwie sehr interessant zur Routenplanung. Ich will einfach danach wissen, wo bin ich lang gelaufen, was habe ich da für Strecken, wenn ich jetzt länger laufe, wo laufe ich da lang und so. Zum Posing ist natürlich auch ganz wichtig, wenn man halt so zeigen will, wo man so lang gelaufen ist. Also nicht für mich jetzt, aber nur für andere Leute. Gut, das lässt sich halt mit der Uhr derzeit noch nicht machen. Und ich bin mir halt auch nicht so sicher, ob man überhaupt in so einer kleinen Uhr einen GPS-Empfänger einbauen könnte. Also jetzt so Antennen empfangstechnisch.
Ich glaube, aber der Stromverbrauch von so einem GPS-Empfänger ist eigentlich ein Problem.
Da gibt es doch schon Uhren mit GPS. Aber das sind halt auch immer so dicke Klopper.
Ja, und wie gut funktionieren die wirklich?
Aber mal abgesehen jetzt davon. Wie war es denn? Na, die Uhr.
Also, was habe ich ausprobiert? Also ich habe so eine normale Apple Watch, also so eine Stahl-Uhr, angehabt. Mit diesem Sportband. Und ich habe dieses Lederband ausprobiert. Und ich habe, glaube ich, was habe ich noch ausprobiert? Diese Milanese Loop habe ich noch ausprobiert. Und dieses Bracelet habe ich auch, doch das habe ich auch noch ausprobiert. Genau.
Aber die Armbände interessieren mich jetzt persönlich gerade.
Tatsächlich ist das, was bei diesen Try-On eigentlich das ist, worum es geht. Weil die Uhr, die du da anmachst, läuft in so einem Demo-Modus. Also du kannst die gar nicht so richtig benutzen. Die Uhr, die in diesem speziellen Demo-Device ist, die kannst du benutzen. Also da kannst du tatsächlich hin und her wischen und Dinge tun. Die Uhr, die du zum Try-On kriegst, die macht die ganze Zeit nur irgendwelche Sachen und simuliert die ganze Zeit, dass du Nachrichten kriegst und Pippa Po. Weil da gibt's ihnen, also Apple zumindest, mehr darum Armband ausprobieren, sieht es hübsch aus, passt es, ist es so, das Band, was du haben willst und so. Weil das ist nun mal, das ist das, was die Leute da am meisten interessiert. Und ich sag erstmal was zu diesen Bändern.
Sehr spannend.
Auch wenn ich das gleich sage, was zu den Bändern.
Also dieses Sportband, das ist schon ganz schön sleek. Also das fühlt sich überhaupt nicht billig an. Das gab es ja an vielen Orten zu lesen. Und ich kann das nur bestätigen. Das ist wirklich ganz schön angenehm, weich und toll. Also da muss man sich gar nicht schämen, das anzuhaben. Das sind ja echt gelungen.
Und angenehm weich heißt in einem Jahr Stein hart, weil die Weichmacher alle weg sind.
Das sind dann alle in deinem Arm drin.
Keine Ahnung, vielleicht. Das Lederarmband fand ich eher unexciting, weil irgendwie so klassischer Verschluss, weiß ich nicht, hat mich irgendwie nicht so umgehauen. Dieses Link-Bracelet konnte ich nicht so richtig testen, weil das hätte ich dann auf meine Größe anpassen müssen.
Hat nicht gepasst. Ich müsste eigentlich auch mal so ein Apple Store gehen. Ich wollte so Link-Dings haben und dann...
Ja, das wäre mal ganz interessant, bei deinen Umfängen da zu sehen, was denn da überhaupt passt. Das ist aber tatsächlich so, dass du wirklich bei diesem Link-Bracelet, da kannst du wirklich diese einzelnen Teile, da hast du wirklich so für jedes einzelne Element, was du rausnehmen kannst, noch mal so einen eigenen Druckknopf. Also man muss die gar nicht groß mechanisch disassemblieren oder so. Und dann, was weiß ich, du gibst das zur Apple, sondern du kannst wirklich da Knopf drücken und die genauso seitlich rausschieben, wie du das ganze Armband an der Uhr befestigst, quasi.
Okay, kein Wunder, dass das so teuer ist.
Jaja, kein Wunder, dass das so teuer ist. Das ist wirklich ein aufwändiges Teil. Naja, mich hat natürlich dann am Ende auch mehr so die Uhr interessiert und diese Bedienung. Und vor allem hat mich natürlich interessiert, zieht mich das Ding jetzt genug, dass ich sage, ich muss was jetzt haben.
Spannung.
Kein Zug.
Hab ich eine bestellt oder nicht?
Keine Ahnung.
Na, was meint ihr denn?
Bestimmt.
Eher nicht.
Zwei zu eins für eher nicht, ja? Hab ich nicht gemacht.
Na, kennen wir dich ja langsam. Vor allen Dingen den Gesichtsausdruck.
Naja, also ich wollte ja irgendwie wissen, ob mich irgendwas total umhaut. Ich glaub, es war, erst mal, also es gibt ja keinen Podcast-Support auf der Uhr, so out of the box. Es gibt zwar jetzt diese Apps, ja? Es gibt jetzt diese Apps, die natürlich Podcasts quasi auf diese Uhr bringen, aber das ist so ein bisschen unklar. Dann war halt nur so diese Aussage, du hast zwei Gigabyte Speicher auf dieser Uhr, also vermutlich hat diese Uhr acht Gigabyte Speicher, das war so das, was ich gehört habe. Zwei Gigabyte sind dafür reserviert, deine Musik zu speichern. Das ist quasi ein zwei Gigabyte iPod.
Acht Gigabyte? Sicher?
Sicher bin ich mir nicht, aber das ist...
Wo sollen die denn hingehen?
Na ja, hallo, hast du mal diese Micro SD-Karten gesehen? Da passen wie viel mittlerweile drauf?
Ja, nein, ich meine, wenn du jetzt zwei Gigabyte für Musik oder Podcasts veranschlagst, dann bleiben ja noch sechs Gigabyte frei. Du erzählst mir doch jetzt nicht, dass jetzt das Betriebssystem nochmal zwei Gigabyte braucht.
Ich dachte nur, ich habe gehört, dass es acht Gigabyte sind und es gibt die Aussage von Apple-Mitarbeitern, dass zwei Gigabyte für Musik reserviert sind.
Die zwei Gigabyte für Musik, die hab ich auch gehört.
Die anderen sechs Gigabyte sind dann halt für das OS bzw.
Oder für Logfiles.
Aber du hast als App nur 30 Megabyte.
Warum will man zwei Gigabyte Musik auf der Uhr haben?
Ja, jetzt mit WatchKit. Aber es wird ja keine neue Uhr auf dem Markt sein und schon wird es native Apps geben. Das ist ja jetzt sozusagen jetzt so. Aber ich habe den Eindruck, dass auch Speicher einfach freigehalten wird für Apps, die dann halt lokal irgendwas speichern. Keine Ahnung.
Ja, oder dieses was beim iPhone hier. Wer hatte nochmal das Problem? Wer macht das Ultraschall nochmal? Ich vergess mal seinen Namen. Der hat doch dieses Problem mit dem mysteriösen Speicherverbrauch auf seinem iPhone, was ja dann irgendwie alle nase-langen resetten musste. Vielleicht haben sie das schon vorgesorgt und möglichst lang Buzzer eingebaut.
Und wozu braucht man jetzt Musik auf der Watch?
Wozu man Musik braucht?
Zum Anhören.
Und ein Pär-Bluetooth-Kopfhörer auch, wenn man sein iPhone nicht dabei hat.
Genau.
Kannst da ein Bluetooth-Kopfhörer dran koppeln.
Die haben doch eh alle iPhone dabei. Den Hipster will ich ja mal sehen, der nur mit seiner Watch rumläuft.
Na, es gibt durchaus Gründe, auch sein Telefon vielleicht mal nicht dabei zu haben.
Nenn mir einen.
Doch, das ist ein Grund, wenn ich jetzt laufe, wenn ich natürlich so wenig Zeug wie möglich habe und ein Telefon ist eigentlich unpraktisch.
Ja, aber auf der anderen Seite kann das auch extrem praktisch sein, zum Beispiel wenn du durch den Park irgendwo Mutterseelen alleinstiefelst, Fuß um Knicks nicht laufen kannst und total gerne jetzt mal jemand anrufen würdest, um Hilfe zu holen.
Meinst du, kannst du dir diese Zeit, wo Menschen kein Telefon hatten, nicht mehr vorstellen? Trotzdem musst du halt das Telefon an dir haben. Und derzeit gibt es ja nur so bekloppte Möglichkeiten. Also entweder hast du noch mal eine Tasche.
Hab ich vorhin erst gesehen, da wo Huckel arbeitet, da ist so ein blondes Mädel beim Joggen gerannt irgendwie, der hatte ihr Telefon so oben am Oberarm, sah ganz entspannt aus, Kopfhörer drin und ist da ganz entspannt lang gejoggt.
Aber richtig geil sind die, die mit den Fablets am Oberarm rumlaufen. Da lege ich mich jedes Mal nie, das sehe ich nicht oft, aber ich habe schon ein paar Mal so Leute mit so ein... Ja, mit irgendwelchen so Riesen-Androids halt.
So ein dickes Samsung-Traner oder ein iPhone 6.
Und dann halt natürlich nicht die entsprechenden Arme dazu. Also das heißt, dass ich dann...
Also ich habe mein 5S mal vor ein paar Tagen, um genau das abzuchecken, habe ich halt auch mal das erste Mal auch nur erwogen, sowas da reinzumachen. Weil du hast es am Abend, weil ich, wenn ja, wenn ich das Telefon dabei habe, dann will ich natürlich auch die Fähigkeiten des Telefons nutzen. Das heißt, ich würde schon mal auf den Bildschirm gucken, wenn das Ding jetzt einmal oberarm ist.
Das geht verdammt schlecht.
Also, das sieht auf jeden Fall ziemlich albern aus. Es würde wahrscheinlich noch irgendwie gehen, aber gut ist anders. Am Unterarm hast du natürlich das Problem, wenn du läufst, dann schlackerst, da hast du also noch mal ein extra Schleudergebiet.
Brauchst du einem anderen Unterarm auch noch eins?
Ja, vor allem musstest du dann das Telefon, also erst mal sieht es natürlich bekloppt aus. Und zweitens musst du das Ding dann auch so fest machen.
Dass es nicht rumeiert.
Dass es nicht rumeiert, das drückt dann auch noch enorm. Also das ist ja wirklich das Letzte, was du haben willst beim Sport. Das ist die Alternative. Aber wenn du dann halt aufs Telefon schauen willst, musst du es halt rauspulen, was beim Laufen auch irgendwie immer ungeil ist. Und dann hast du noch ein Kabel dran. Okay, vielleicht bist du dann mit Bluetooth-Kopfhörer ganz modernt.
Und so eine Uhrmeiste, die wäre voll toll. Da macht man so den einen Arm nach vorne zum Gucken und den anderen Arm macht man vorne zum irgendwie drauf rumklicken. Und dann muss man es voll nah dran machen, weil er ist ja so klein. Dabei wackelt alles. Das heißt, du siehst eigentlich gar nichts.
Du musst dich ja gar nicht drücken oder an diesem Rädchen betreten.
Du brauchst das ja gar nicht schönreden, weil du hast ja gar keine bestellt. Du musst ja gar nicht verteidigen.
Ich verteidige auch.
Du musst jetzt mal sagen, warum du sie nicht bestellt hast.
Ich war mir einfach noch nicht sicher, welche ich jetzt eigentlich wirklich haben wollen würde und ob das Geld, was ich dann dafür ausgebe, gerechtfertigt ist. Ganz einfach. Das war einfach eine ganz ökonomische Entscheidung. Ich wollte ja auch noch mal abwarten, wie das jetzt hier so mit diesem Display ist. So mit dem Kratzkram. Jetzt kamen ja diese Kratztests, die ersten im Web. Da ist schon so, du kannst halt diese normale Sport-Aluo-Sache mit dem normalen Glas, die kriegt man schon ganz gut zerkratzt.
Gut, ich meine, die sind ja jetzt mit Sandpapier rangegangen.
Ich glaube, da haben viele Leute auch noch kein verstandenes Problem mit diesen beiden Gläsern da. Und so, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, dann ist dieses Ion-Glas, das heißt so heißt es da, oder?
Ja, so nennen sie das.
Ja, für die Sport-Uhr, das ist zwar nicht so kratzfest wie das Saphir-Glas für die größeren Uhren, oder für die mit dem...
Aber lässt mehr Licht durch.
Nee, aber ist halt flexibler. Das heißt, der Saphir, das kann eigentlich schneller brechen. Das ist nämlich ein bisschen spröde. Das zerkratzt nicht so schnell, aber es bricht schneller. Das Ion ist vielleicht nicht so kratzfest, aber es kann sich besser ein bisschen biegen, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe.
Ob das jetzt am Ende entscheidend ist, aber das ist natürlich schon so ein Punkt, weil Ua heißt auch, du kommst halt schneller mal irgendwo gegen, stößt irgendwo gegen. Also das mit dem Kratzen wäre für mich schon so ein Ding, das spricht für mich eher darauf. Also ich tendiere eher halt zu so einer nicht-Alu-Variante. Das ist dann halt auch wieder ganz schön viel Geld. Ganz einfach mal.
Und dafür, dass es nicht so richtig viel kann, kann man auch nicht mal Podcasts abspielen.
Das wollte ich dann erst mal abwarten. Also nicht autark. Also wenn das Ding autark, wenn ich weiß, ich könnte mein Telefon mal beiseite lassen, könnte loslaufen und dabei Podcasts hören. Die einzige Möglichkeit, das jetzt zu machen, ist Podcasts als Musik vorhalten. Da sind wir wieder in diesem manuellen Verwalten, Scheißdreck mit keinen richtigen Controls und keine Kapitelmarken und Pipapo. Und dann da draufsünden, wie auf so ein iPod. Und dann hätte man das vielleicht unter Umständen. Wusste ich jetzt nicht so richtig, ob ich das... Das zweite Problem, warum ich keine Uhr bestellt habe, was so ein bisschen das Totschland-Argument ist, dadurch, dass ich jetzt die ganze Zeit zwischen Berlin und Deutschland hin und her...
Berlin und Deutschland.
Berlin und Deutschland. Ja, ist ja richtig.
Zwischen Berlin, Deutschland und England hin und her reise, wüsste ich jetzt gar nicht, wo ich es mir hätte hinschicken lassen können, weil ich kann es ja nicht einfach im Laden kaufen. Sondern man kann die ja derzeit nur online bestellen und sich zuschicken lassen.
Bis das kommt, bist du schon längst wieder da?
Und dann wäre nur England gegangen. Und dann war ja schon der erste Tag rum. Und dann hieß es, ja, jetzt kommen sie sowieso erst im Juni. Und dann war es mir dann egal. Dann dachte ich mir, dann warte ich halt jetzt einfach, bis sich die Situation beruhigt hat. Da sind schon genug Tests draußen, was irgendwie taugt und was nicht taugt. Dann hat man sich das Ding auch das fünfte Mal angeschaut. Und man wird ja dann auch schon so ein bisschen eitel, auch wenn man sich irgendwie diesen Urnenkram gibt. Das ist ja schon ein bisschen ein merkwürdiger Effekt.
Und wie hat die Uhr so sich da so an diesem Arm gemacht? Ist die fett oder ist die nicht fett?
Also ich hatte die große dran und ich dachte mir, die ist ja gar nicht fett. An meinem Arm.
Sie haben ja auch so einen zierlichen Modelärmchen da in ihrer Werbung.
Keine Ahnung. Ich hab das Ding nicht so sehr als Fremdkörper empfunden. Ich fand die weder zu dick noch zu groß. Das war ja eigentlich meine ursprüngliche Erwartung. Das war so ein bisschen meine erste Reaktion.
Das haben ja wohl viele berichtet, dass im Gegensatz zu allen anderen Uhren oder Smartwatches, überhaupt dicken Uhren, die es so gibt, dass sie gar nicht so fett ist. Aber das, finde ich, ändert ja nichts an der Tatsache, dass dann halt alle Uhren fett sind. Nicht nur die, aber es ist ja trotzdem fett.
Du meinst, der Johnny hat seinen Job gut gemacht?
Ich finde, das Ding sieht schick aus. Also das kann man mal jetzt echt nicht anders sagen. Ich habe mir vor allem jetzt mal auch mal so Uhren in Uhrengeschäften angeschaut.
Ja, das ist schlimm. Das ist schlimm. Das darf man nicht anfangen.
Geh mal in so ein Uhren- oder stell dich mal nur so vor so einer Auslage von so einem Uhrengeschäft und schau dir mal an, was die für Uhren da verkaufen. Vor allem was für Preisen die Uhren verkaufen. Das war so der Moment, wo ich mir dachte, okay.
Vor allem die Kombination zu was für Preisen die was für Uhren verkaufen.
Also das ist ja unglaublich. Also ich kriege meinen Hirn gar nicht drum gewickelt, wie man überhaupt bereit sein kann, aber Tausende von Euro für Uhren auszugeben, die gerade mal eine Zeit anzeigen können und vielleicht mal so ein Datum oder vielleicht noch eine Temperatur. Das ist aber schon mega sophisticated. Und die sehen einfach total furchtbar aus. Also furchtbar vor allem auch so in der wie soll ich sagen, in dieser Anzeige-Ergonomie. Also eine Uhr ist ja etwas, was mir eine Information vermitteln will. Aber die allermeisten Uhren, die man so sieht...
Das ist auch Statussymbol einfach, würde ich sagen.
Ja, aber ich frage mich halt, was ist denn daran jetzt eigentlich der... Also wie kann ich auch nur das Gefühl haben, dass mein Status aufgewertet wird von etwas, was mir versucht, eine Information zu vermitteln, das aber so schlecht macht? Also in meinem Nerd-Pride bin ich da, kann ich da nicht folgen. Weil ich würde nur stolz sein auf etwas, was mir die Information ja effizient vermittelt. Und der einzige Punkt, wo ich finde, wo die anderen Uhren der Apple Watch noch was gegenüber haben, ist, dass die sich halt nicht einschalten müssen. Was man leider mit dieser Demo-Geschichte nicht testen kann, ist dieses automatische Einschalten. Dadurch, dass da die ganze Zeit so ein Demogramm draufläuft, kannst du diesen Effekt nicht machen. Also das ist insofern total blöd. Du gehst in den Laden, willst schauen, wie würde denn diese Uhr so für mich funktionieren? Und du kannst die wichtigste Funktion, nämlich die schalte ich automatisch ein, wenn ich draufschaue, gar nicht testen. Und viele haben halt gesagt, da ist so ein Delay drin. Und du kannst halt, ich meine, wenn man so eine Uhr, so eine normale Uhr am Arm hat, dann kann man die, auch wenn man nicht so eine blöde Bewegung macht, immer sehen. Ja, die liegt irgendwo rum, schaust auf die Uhr drauf. Du musst nicht immer so eine affige, aktiviere dich. Das ist so ein bisschen wie dieses Hey Siri. Dieses Hinbetteln zum Computer. Ja, kommunizieren mit mir, sag mir was. Und das war auch so ein Punkt. Ich konnte das halt nicht testen und da war, wollte ich die Katze einfach nicht im Sack kufen. Weil am Ende ist das noch blöd. Aber trotzdem, diese anderen Uhren sind scheiße teuer.
Aber es gibt auch genug...
Ja, aber es gibt keine einzige, die ordentlich aussieht. Also wo dieses Watchface mal klar ist. Und das ist bei der Apple Watch super gelöst. Also die sind einfach so schön.
Ich bezweite, dass du schon alle guten Uhren gesehen hast. Einfach mal direkt so aus dem Steg reisen.
Also angeblich haben sich die Jungs von Run DMC damals Rolex umgeschnallt, wo sie extra die Zeige haben entfernen lassen, nur um zu demonstrieren, dass es sich jetzt wirklich nur um ein Statussymbol handelt.
Ja, ich glaube, es gibt da echt verschiedene Zielgruppen auch. Und die Statussymbol-Zielgruppe, da zählt weder die Information noch sonst irgendwas. Da zählt nur, wie viel Brillanten da draufstecken oder so.
Habt ihr das Foto gesehen von Karl Lagerfeld mit seiner Apple Watch Gold Edition da? Der hatte die noch in dem Pairing-Modus. Also da war noch dieses Pair mich mal bitte mit dem iPhone. Er hat das sozusagen nicht in Betrieb genommen. Er hat das Teil sozusagen erhalten, an den Arm gemacht und keinerlei Setup zu Ende gebracht zumindest. Und wurde damit abgelichtet. Und Beyoncé hatte auch so eine Goldwatch und die hatten ja sozusagen auch eine, die man gar nicht kaufen kann. Also die offiziell gar nicht angeboten wird mit diesem Link-Bracelet in Gold. Also komplett Gold. Was weiß ich, was das Ding kostet? Wahrscheinlich 30.000 Euro oder so was. Oder die 55.000 Euro, wie hier im Vorspann unserer Sendung übrigens, hintend. Und die sah aber wiederum ganz gut aus. Nur, dass Beyoncé sie halt falsch rumgetragen hat. Also sie hatte sie am rechten Arm, aber mit dem Knopf rechts. Was man wohl auch tatsächlich so konfigurieren kann, weil du kannst dieses V-Rum-Trickel...
Ja, du konfigurierst ja dann nichts.
Genau, die hat einfach das... Die hat sie nicht unkonfiguriert für den Rechtshändler, aber hat sie einfach auf rechts getragen, aber nicht umkonfiguriert. Einfach rübergeschoben sozusagen.
Genau, aber ich meine wer würde denn so eine Uhr...
Und da jemand, der nicht weiß, dass man umstellen kann.
Nein, wer würde denn überhaupt die Uhr mit der Crown nach rechts zeigend am rechten Arm haben?
Ja ich, jede normale Uhr, weil die mich nicht umdringt.
Ein Linkshänder, der nicht weiß, dass er so umstellen kann.
Wieso würdest du die denn dann rechts tragen?
Weil ich Linkshänder bin.
Ja und?
Ich weiß nicht, letzten Folgen gehört...
Ja, aber du kannst aber als Linkshänder... Da kommst du doch trotzdem nicht ran. Das ist doch vollkommen bekloppt.
Ja natürlich.
Aber wieso, was macht denn das für die... Was macht denn das für die Uhr den Unterschied?
Ja, aber wenn du eine normale Uhr hast, eine normale Uhr hast, dann ist die Crown rechts, ist so.
Ja, aber warum willst du das?
So und wenn du die rechts trägst, dann hast du die natürlich, ja, dann musst du da...
Aber, Roddy, was spielt das denn jetzt für eine Rolle bei der Uhr, ob du links oder rechts Händer bist? Also warum trägst du dann die Uhr auch andersrum?
Weil, wenn du mit der linken Hand schreibst und du hast da so einen Klunker, der die ganze Zeit, während du schreibst, da so Klang Klang Klang auf dem Tisch Klang Klang Klang macht, dann ist das scheiße.
Weißt du, als die Leute Uhr hingetragen haben, haben wir sie auch noch selber geschrieben.
Also es ist jetzt so, ich erzähle so aus meiner Jugend vielleicht jetzt auch, aber... Als man noch schrieb, Schroop.
Schroop. Schroop.
Als man noch Schroop.
Es gab gar keine Linkshänderuhr?
Nö. Echt nicht?
Nein.
Aber es sind doch 10 Prozent. Das heißt, die Apple Watch ist auch die erste richtige Linkshänderuhr?
Eventuell. Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Gibt es bestimmt auch Linkshänderuhr.
Ja, gibt bestimmt auch Linkshänderuhr.
Aber es kommen gleich drei Linkshänder im Chat.
Zumindest kannst du die Apple Watch out of the box konfigurieren. Und alles ist super. Du kannst halt sagen, ob du links oder rechts trägst und wie rum und oben und unten und so weiter.
Nee, wenn du sie umdrehst, hast du halt den Button oben und die Crown unten. Du musst jetzt jeder selber entscheiden, ob das toll aussieht oder nicht.
Weiß ich auch nicht, ob das toll aussieht oder nicht.
Und wie findest du dieses User-Interface, diese runden Teile, die da so rein- und rauszoomen und so? Mir spricht das überhaupt gar nicht an.
Also ohne das jetzt wirklich mit einem eigenen Setup benutzt zu haben, ist das wirklich sehr schwer. Also da muss man wirklich jetzt mal ein paar Tage mit dem Ding durch die Gegend gelaufen sein. Das sind wir jetzt mal echt nicht die Leute. Wenn das interessiert, da eine kluge Aussage zu bekommen, dann müsst ihr auch welche anderen Podcasts hören mit so Frühstellern. Geht schon wahrscheinlich irgendwie. Kann man wahrscheinlich auch etwas dran optimieren. Kann ich nicht sagen. Default ist das Ding halt Uhr. Und von da aus kommst du halt schnell in die Notifications oder in diese Glances. Das ist halt eigentlich das Ding. Du bist immer in der Uhr. Und dann swipest du von unten nach oben. Und dann hast du glaube ich diese Glances. Also da hast du sozusagen so pro Swipe siehst du halt immer so ein Ding, was dir irgendwas genauer anzeigt. Das Wetter, Pippa Po. Und nach oben hast du dann halt die Notifications. Und das ist es eigentlich auch. Und dann kannst du halt da mit diesem Force Touch rumspielen und diese Uhr tippt dich halt die ganze Zeit an. Dieses Taptic ist irgendwie geil. Also das hat schon was. Aber auch das muss man erstmal so richtig testen mit Navigation und so. Es gibt ja dann so merkwürdige Sequenzen an deinen Armen. Ja, und ich hab jetzt kein Heartbeat übertragen. Und es ging ja alles nicht. So, hier der Chat meldet sich schon. Hier hat jemand Apple Watch und findet sie extrem praktisch. Also praktisch, das kann schon sein. Die Frage ist halt nur, was erwartet man sich davon? Also Leute, die jetzt auch schon eine Uhr tragen, sind glaube ich die optimale Zielgruppe. Also wer ohnehin immer die Uhrzeit am Arm erwartet, hat ja dann schon mal eine wunderbare Anwendung.
Ich hab so das Gefühl, also von denen, was ich so gehört hab, dass gerade die Leute, die viel Uhr tragen und den Wert darauf haben, irgendwie schnell auf den Arm gucken zu können und sofort die Uhrzeit zu sehen, sind eher enttäuscht davon, dass sie diese komische Ich mach die Uhr an-Bewegung machen müssen. Die dann halt auch mitunter sowas Plakatives hat, weil man nicht so mal so unauffällig schnell mal gucken kann.
In so einem Meeting mal so...
Ich sitze halt die ganze Zeit vorm Rechner, da ist immer eine Uhr, freue ich mich.
Ja, das ist der unauffällige Blick rechts oben. Also ich meine 21 Uhr 38.
Naja, ich meine, es ist sehr interessant zu sehen, wie Apple diese Uhr ja selber präsentiert. Also was sie quasi als Grund liefern, warum du dieses Gerät haben wollen würdest. Es gibt genau drei Primäranwendungen. Es gibt Zeit. Und ich würde sagen, es ist halt eine hoch konfigurierbare, korrekte Uhr, die schicke Modi hat, die andere Uhren einfach nicht haben. Damit diese Planetenkonstellation... Mickey-Mäuse. Aber auch, dass du dir mit diesen Complications schön konfigurieren kannst, was ich zum Beispiel in eine andere Weltzeit an der richtigen Stelle einblende. Also genau die Informationen, die du sehen möchtest, nicht mehr und nicht weniger, kannst du dir da sehr einfach zusammen konfigurieren. Du klickst, machst einmal so einen Force-Touch auf die Uhr drauf, selber, wenn die Uhr anzeigt, dann kannst du so verschiedene Presets durchwischen. Du kannst dir vorher quasi so ein Setup machen und zwischen diesen Setups schnell hin und her schalten. Also kannst du dir so drei oder vier oder fünf verschiedene Watchfaces zusammen konfigurieren. So nach dem Motto, jetzt habe ich so einen Business-Modus, jetzt habe ich so einen Casual-Modus, jetzt habe ich einen Beyoncé-Modus und jetzt habe ich irgendwie, keine Ahnung, so einen Show-Off-Modus und kannst jederzeit dir weitere Watchfaces da zusammenklicken. Und das finde ich schon sehr sleek. Das ist irgendwie nett, weil ich habe auch unterschiedliche Mitteilungsbedürfnisse. Gerade dieses, das könnte ich mir gut vorstellen, eine andere Weltzeit immer im Blick zu haben. Das Problem hast du auch, ne? Du hast immer auch zumindest eine Zeitzone, die für dich echt wichtig ist.
Zwei.
Genau, wenn man die eine weiß, weiß man die andere wahrscheinlich dann auch schon.
Nee, Westküste und Shanghai.
Ja, ich eigentlich auch zwei. Also ich bräuchte derzeit auf jeden Fall immer...
Und England, aber das zählt nicht.
Malaysia. Ja, sag das mal nicht. Ich bin ganz schön verwirrt, muss ich sagen. Immer mit dem Stundevorstunde zurück, das macht eigentlich total madig.
Du musst doch überlegen, wo die Sonne aufgeht.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie die das in den USA machen. Wir sind ja immer gewohnt mit unserem Computer, also in Deutschland haben wir es ja in der Regel immer mit einer Zeit zu tun. Aber wenn du jetzt in den USA viel mit anderen Leuten zu tun hast...
Das wären nur drei Stunden.
Was?
Unterschied.
Ja, aber...
Neustundesküste sind drei.
Ja, und dann hast du noch Alaska, Hawaii.
Die zählen eh nicht.
Ja, ist ja egal, aber mach mal einen Telco-Termin und da ist das dann schon entscheidend, ob es eine Stunde mehr oder weniger ist.
Das sollten sich eh alle nur an UTC halten, das ist das Beste.
Das funktioniert aber nicht.
Das wär aber schön.
Ja, schön, aber auch in England gibt es Sommerzeit. Also das ist alles total gaga.
Viel schlimmer, aber UTC ist UTC.
Ich wollte aber jetzt gerade auf die Uhr nochmal zurück. Das ist sozusagen das eine. Die Apple Watch ist eine coole Uhr, kann man schon mal festhalten. Und sie sieht deutlich besser aus als alle anderen Uhren.
Zumindest alle anderen Smartwatches.
Nee, auch alle anderen Uhren.
Die du bisher gesehen hast.
Ja, zeig mir eine Uhr, die geil aussieht. Ich hab da noch nicht die teure. Also ich geh in so einen Uhrenladen, ich fand das noch nie toll. Ich komm mir da vor wie in so einem... Weiß nicht, wie so Tandläden, wo dieser ganze Schmuck... Es gibt schon coole Uhren.
Ich kann dir jetzt nicht so aus dem Stegreif welche herzaubern.
Ja okay, es gibt vielleicht irgendeine coole Uhr, die genau ein Modus macht. Aber diese Apple Watch ist halt alle diese coole Uhren, die du dir selber jederzeit zusammen konfigurieren kannst.
Das möchte ich noch bezweifeln.
Okay, kann man auch anders sehen, seh ich jetzt so. Zweiter Teil ist dieser Fitnessaspekt. Da ist sicherlich noch einiges zu holen. Das hab ich natürlich jetzt auch noch nicht ausprobiert, aber das ist definitiv eine Anwendung. Für Leute, die laufen und die irgendwie Sport machen, ist einfach das Handgelenk der richtige Ort. Das trägt nicht dick auf, das ist ein Gewicht, das nimmt man einfach mit. Und du kannst, während du voll in Action bist, da immer irgendwie drauf schauen. Und mit Apps oder mit der eingebauten Fitness-App, du kriegst einfach die Informationen, die du haben willst. Die Zeit, die du noch hast, die du laufen bist, den Speed, den du drauf hast, die Heartrate, was weiß ich. So, die dritte Anwendung, was war das noch gleich? Das ist ja nochmal ein ganz anderer Aspekt. Ah ja, genau, die Kommunikation. Vielen Dank.
Schauen, ja, aber das hebt doch erst so richtig ab, wenn es genug Leute gibt, die so eine Uhr dann auch haben und so wie den man dann so eine Kommunikation betreiben kann, weil hier Heartbeats senden oder so ein Dudel.
Nein, messaging einfach.
Ja gut, messaging schon, ja.
Messaging, Audio-Messaging.
Aber da muss man dann auch abwarten, wie gut das dann zum Beispiel in Deutsch funktioniert. So dieses wollen wir das machen oder das und dann bekommst du die zwei Buttons, wo du dann auswählen kannst.
Ja, du kannst ja auch diktieren.
Jaja, das kannst du auch.
Wow, das macht sich immer ein Telefon mit Syrien.
Ja, wobei in die Uhr sprechen, das hat natürlich so ein bisschen was von Dick Tracy.
Na ja, eher wie hieß der Kit?
Nein, das hat was von Dick Tracy.
Knight Rider.
Nein, da brauchst du ja ein ganzes Auto. Na ja, Dick Tracy hat seine ganze Kommunikation über die Armbanduhr gemacht. Ja, das ist schön für Dick Tracy, aber ich meine, das wirkt ja irgendwie schon so ein bisschen wie, ja, so könnte Kommunikation eigentlich sein. Ich glaube, Dick Tracy hatte noch Video dabei, aber das werden wir sicherlich auch bald sehen. Ich schätze mal, in zwei Jahren gibt es auch Video auf der Uhr. Tja, irgendjemand meinte auf Twitter, in vier Jahren gibt es die Apple Watch nicht mehr. Ja, ohne Gründe, kann ich auch nur sagen.
Gibt es eigentlich so einen Navi auf der Watch? Ja, ne? So eine Navigationshilfe? Beim Laufen und so? So ein Mini links, rechts, geradeaus?
Ja, und der Tab legt dich dann immer an, wenn du jetzt die Richtung wechseln musst.
Genau, wenn du nach links und rechts abbiegen musst, hast du so unterschiedliche Tab-Sequenzen, die dann so reingedrückt werden. Und das ist irgendwie, ja, nette Interaktion. Also mal schauen, vielleicht... Ich glaube, über kurz oder lang kriegen sie mich.
Klick mal rauf da.
Die Dick Tracy-Uhr.
Gibt's wieder einen... Ja, genau. Also wir blicken gerade auf Dick Tracy mit seiner Uhr. Die nicht ganz so aussieht, wie die Apple Watch, weil die hat eine komische Antenne noch nach links und nach rechts. Das ist sozusagen die Apple Watch 3.
Ja, mit so viel Tand und Schnick Schnack nix da. Bestenfalls Samsung. Und selbst die machen nicht so viel Schnick Schnack.
Und meint er, dass von der Apple Watch nächstes Jahr schon eine neue rauskommt?
Möglich, aber darauf wetten würde ich jetzt nicht wollen. Ja doch, wahrscheinlich schon.
Aber mehr so Silent Upgrade, nicht so ein riesen Ding, oder?
Naja, also wenn du dir anguckst zwischen iPhone und iPhone 3G oder iPad, iPad 2. Also ich glaube, ein Update wird es geben, aber kein riesengroßes.
Also ein Jahr Entwicklung heißt, die Prozessoren werden schneller und kleiner und das bedeutet, dass du dieselbe Tätigkeit mit weniger Stromverbrauch machen kannst. Und das ist für die Uhr natürlich ein riesen Argument.
Ich glaube, die verbrauchen gar nicht so viel. Ich glaube, das Display ist wahrscheinlich das, was am meisten schluckt, oder?
Na am meisten ist das eine, aber das Display ist ja auch nicht unbedingt immer an. Ja. So, aber das Aufwachen, dann was tun und dann wieder schlafen gehen. Erinner dich, als sie bei Mavericks da diese Optimierungen gemacht haben. Da haben sie halt vor allem dieses Reschaffling in der Zeit gemacht, damit man nach einmal Aufwecken mehr tun kann, damit man nicht so oft aufgeweckt wird, weil das häufige Aufwachen und wieder runterfahren.
Dieses Time-Acquire-Lessing.
Genau, weil das einfach so viel Zeit verbraucht hat, wo du dich erst mal hochfahren musst.
Ja, aber das war ja so im Millisekundenbereich, dieses Time-Acquire-Lessing.
Ja, ich meine jetzt auch nicht, dass das Thema generell gilt. Wenn die Uhr sich schneller wieder abschalten kann, weil das, was sie tun muss, schon getan ist, dann verbraucht sie natürlich weniger Strom. Na gut. Deswegen ist ja auch zum Beispiel der Stromverbrauch mit WLAN AC geringer als mit N oder G. Weil die Timeslots da kleiner sind. So viel zur Apple Watch. Interessant fand ich, dass das Ding ja wohl auch ordentlich wasserdicht ist.
Naja, zumindest wasserdichter als sie es versprechen.
Ja, ich meine, da sind irgendwie Leute minutenlang unter Wasser gewesen.
Das hast du schon gelernt, dass du bei gewissen Sachen eben halt eher weniger versprechst. Damit sie es auf jeden Fall einhalten und später die Leute selber berichten, dass es ja doch ein Stück besser ist, als sie sagen. Haben sie mit Batterien ja auch irgendwann angefangen, ne? Vor Jahren.
Und mit Lieferzeiten.
Wo wir bei Neuigkeiten sind, was ich nicht bisher in die Hand bekommen habe, ist das neue MacBook. Hätte das jemand von euch schon mal?
Nö, aber ich hab's auch nicht drauf angelegt, also.
Interessiert euch nicht?
Na prinzipiell schon, aber es ist sowieso kein Gerät, was ich haben möchte. Würde ich's mir gerne mal anschauen und uh, und oh, und ist ja toll und spannend sagen, aber ansonsten... Ich...
Mich interessiert halt diese Tastatur, ob die irgendwie damit leben kann oder nicht.
Ja, aber dann soll mal das nächste 15 Zoll rauskommen mit USB 3C und Tastatur und allem anderem schönen Schnick Schnack. Dann können wir wieder reden.
Die Frage ist ja...
Und am besten 15 Zoll, was auch kleiner geworden ist, weil sie noch mal mehr Rand eingespart haben, das heißt, Display weiterhin 15 Zoll, aber trotzdem ist der Rechner ein Stück kleiner. Das würde ich gut finden.
Dünner vor allem.
Ja, so ein großes Display ist schon cool, aber sie können am Rand schon noch eine Menge einsparen, finde ich. Da geht noch was. Also, es sind ja locker drei Zentimeter, die da links, also insgesamt links, rechts weg können und oben sind es auch locker zwei. Also, das sind schon anderthalb Zentimeter hier rechts, oder? Das ist halt links und rechts, also kommen drei Zentimeter zusammen. Ich würde sagen, es sind sogar fast zwei hier.
Was, sie haben den alten Mann überfallen für nur 50 Mark?
Boah, 50 Mark hier, 50 Mark da, da kommt ganz schön was zusammen.
Ja, unklar. Also, irgendwie scheinen sie auf jeden Fall Probleme zu haben, diesen ganzen Kram in die Läden zu bekommen und das finde ich dann doch bemerkenswert. Also, haben sie da nicht genug von produziert?
Vielleicht produzieren sie die wieder in den USA?
Ich bestimmt nicht.
Da ist kein Zoch drin. Das ist eigentlich aus dem Mac Pro geworden.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Was ich sehr gut fand an diesem ganzen Launch, kein Geklatsche. Ist euch das schon mal aufgefallen? Kein Giole, kein Geklatsche.
Ich hatte die Website offen, ich hab keinen Geklatsche gehört.
Ich bin einfach in diesen Apple-Laden reingegangen und da waren dann die Uhren und war okay. Keiner musste einem irgendwie high fiving und irgendwie blöde Schlangen und so.
Das verstehe ich auch gar nicht. Wie auf diese Idee gekommen ist, der gehört entlassen.
Was?
Diesem Geklatsche.
Aber ich glaube, das sind auch wieder nur wir, die das irgendwie finden. Ja, die anderen finden das geil. Ich meine, Leute stellen sich da ja an. Die machen ja da mit. Und wir hatten ja auch schon mal den geheimen Bericht eines Applestore-Mitarbeiters.
Wer weiß, vielleicht gehen ja mit einem auch die Endorphine durch, wenn man da in so einer Schlange steht und dann endlich dran ist.
Für Leute, also ich weiß nicht, dieses Leben in der modernen Konsumwelt. Das ist exciting, ja genau und konsumierst du was, bist du was. Also das ist ja auch das Ding bei dieser ganzen Apple Watch. Du bist da einfach Teil des modernen Lebens und Teil unserer Welt, wenn du halt am Konsum teilnimmst. Und du bist halt noch mal was Besonderes, wenn du besonders viel teilnimmst und wenn du besonders viel Geld bezahlt hast. Ja, auf Sachen wirfst, die...
Wird das schon wieder beim nächsten Thema, bei den Quartalszahlen?
Ja, fällt. Ja, hast du da einen Kommentar zu?
Habst du denn wieder neue?
Ja, vorgestern schon wieder ein Quartal rum.
War wieder für...
Ja, sie verkaufen Chat-Loud von dem ganzen Quatsch.
Aber Quar 1 ist doch eigentlich immer das schlechteste Quartal, ne?
Ja, das ist aber das zweitdickste Quartal, was wir je hatten. Also das schlägt das vorletzte Weihnachtsquartal sogar.
Oh man, naja.
Ich glaube, es hat sogar das letzte Weihnachtsquartal gestanden. Also nicht, was es gerade war, sondern das vom letzten Jahr. So rum, mehr ist das vorletzt, okay.
Ja, und der Grund ist der, dass halt jetzt aus diesem Quartal jetzt auch ein Weihnachtsquartal geworden ist, weil in China jetzt quasi das chinesische Neujahr da reinfällt. Und die jetzt in China auch halt alle anfangen, sich wie Blöde Sachen zu kaufen. Das war wohl früher noch nicht ganz so extrem, aber mittlerweile ist natürlich da der Konsum auch der Herr allen wirkens geworden. Sie kaufen sich halt jetzt alle iPhones. Aber es gab auch in Deutschland, wenn ich das richtig gelesen habe, 80% mehr iPhone-Verkäufer.
80%! Was aber interessant war, die iPads sind ja zurückgegangen, ganz schön deutlich auch. Und dass der Mac-Markt ist, glaube ich, vom Umsatz her größer als der iPad-Markt. Es waren irgendwie so 5,6 und 5,7 oder 8 Milliarden oder so. Es sind so unter 200 Millionen Unterschied. Also das heißt, die Macs kommen wieder. Die iPads waren gar nicht so spannend. Die versinken wieder. Die versinken nicht, aber sie schwächen sich ein bisschen ab gerade. Und ich denke, man schwächt sich auch noch ein bisschen weiter ab. Die halten einfach zu lange die Teile. Da kauft man nicht jedes Jahr ein neues.
Ja, beziehungsweise die Leute haben gemerkt, dass das iPad eigentlich ein Gadget ist, weil es dafür nicht die Software gibt, um das wirklich produktiv einzusetzen.
Das stimmt nicht.
Also es ist ein super Gerät für zum Beispiel meine Oma.
Nee, das stimmt einfach nicht. Ich meine, die meisten Leute, die jetzt... Wie war das? Also 40% glaube ich hier im westlichen Markt und in China 70% aller Leute, die ein iPad gekauft haben, haben ja erstes iPad gekauft. Das heißt, alle Leute, die jetzt... Also es gibt immer noch viele... Die meisten Leute steigen neu ein. Oder ein signifikanter Teil steigt überhaupt erst neu in diese Kategorie ein.
Ja, aber heißt das, dass viele Leute kein weiteres kaufen? Warum kommt denn die kein weiteres?
Weil die einfach so lange halten. Die gehen erstmal nicht kaputt. Ich meine, diese iPads, die haben einfach...
Mein Telefon geht auch nicht kaputt und ich hab's weggegeben, mir ein neues geholt.
Ja, aber Telefone sind nochmal ein anderes Ding. Das hat dann auch was mit diesen Verträgen zu tun. Du kaufst die Dinger, hast einen Zwei-Jahres-Vertrag. Dann laufen die Dinger wieder neu ab. Ja, aber so ist das. Außerdem haben die Telefone auch nennenswerte neue Features, was Datengeschwindigkeiten und so weiter betrifft. Wenn du mal schaust, dann hat sich da eben auch sehr viel getan im Bereich Bildschirmgröße. Da sehen wir noch sehr viel Dynamik in der technischen Entwicklung bei den Telefonen. Vielleicht hat das auch nochmal was mit Statussymbol zu tun. Aber lassen wir mal die Telefone außen vor. Bloß beim iPad ist es so, die haben schon ihren Markt, werden aber natürlich jetzt auch kannibalisiert auf der einen Seite von den großen Telefonen. Viele Leute werden sich für so einen 6 Plus entscheiden und sagen, was brauche ich da noch, einen iPad Mini? Du kaufst nicht einen iPad Mini und einen 6 Plus, sondern du kaufst entweder oder. Da hat natürlich das 6 Plus den Vorteil, dass du damit auch noch telefonieren kannst. Es ist dann nur geringfügig kleiner als einen iPad Mini. An der Stelle werden quasi iPad-Verkäufe zu Telefonen käufen, was sich ja dann auch bei den vielen Telefonen zeigt. Das ist wahrscheinlich genauso im Android-Markt. Auf der anderen Seite, wo du jetzt ein großes iPad hast, da ist dann natürlich auch schon wieder die Frage, du arbeitest da produktiv mit, du willst da irgendwie komplexere Dinge mit machen. Dann kommen halt so was wie diese neuen MacBooks daher, die auch schlank sind, die nicht mehr solche fetten Klötze sind. Als das iPad kamen, waren halt die Computer, die die Alternative waren, viel schwerer. Also richtig viel schwerer. Und jetzt kommen so die Airs und jetzt das neue MacBook. Das neue MacBook wiegt das Doppelte von so einem iPad Air. Klar ist das Doppelte, aber viele sagen sich dann, naja, hab ich aber noch eine Tastatur dran und so weiter und kann auch mit der Software anders arbeiten. Also ich denke, dass sowohl die Macs von dem iPad-Markt wegziehen als auch die Telefone und dass das für Apple kein Verlust ist. Sondern da kaufen die Leute einfach nur andere Apple-Produkte. Und die iPads selber kriegen wahrscheinlich ihren, ich kauf mir jetzt ein neues iPad-Zyklus, wahrscheinlich erst zwei, drei Jahre später. Während die Telefone alle zwei Jahre gekauft werden, würde es mich nicht wundern, wenn so. Ein iPad alle drei, vier Jahre so ein Renewal-Zyklus hat. Ich meine, ich hab ja hier auch noch so ein iPad 3 rumliegen und das iPad Mini und ich hab nicht auch nur im geringsten irgendeinen Bedarf, das auch fast aktuell ist, weil ich dann den Unterschied nicht so richtig sehe.
Ja, ein Teil des Ganzen könnte natürlich auch sein, dass die iPads nach wie vor fast, ich glaube fast alle ja vom iPad 2 ab, alle auf 8, iOS 8 noch laufen. Also das iPad 1, da ist ja bei iOS 5 oder so Schluss gewesen. Aber das iPad 2, das wird ja nach wie vor mitgezogen und alle anderen iPads. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass wenn sie irgendwie anfangen, iOS-Ipads abzuhängen, dass es dann eventuell anders aussieht mit dem Updaten.
Das werden sie wahrscheinlich bei der nächsten Runde auch machen. Weil das natürlich für die App-Developer auch ein echtes Problem ist, diese alten Geräte immer noch unterstützen zu müssen. Muss man ja auch, weil man das nicht ausschließen kann.
Na ja, sagen wir mal so. Wenn du dir das anguckst, also hier iOS-Support-Matrix, weise ich ja mal gerne drauf hin. Wenn du dir anguckst, was für Geräte sie bei einem Update rausschmeißen, dann läuft es immer über Speicher. Alle anderen Features sind egal, aber Speicher. Speicher ist das, wo sie dann anfangen, die Geräte rauszuwerfen.
Nö, es war auch teilweise Grafikkarten und teilweise auch 32-Bit und 64-Bit.
Das waren die Macs.
Ach so, du bist jetzt bei iOS.
Ach so, okay. Wenn du dir anguckst, bei iOS 6 sind, glaube ich, die 256er-Geräte rausgeflogen. Und bei iOS 7 nochmal ein letztes irgendwie. Und das iPad 2, das hat ja jetzt auch 512 MB Speicher.
Das fliegt als nächstes raus.
Ja, also ich kann mir vorstellen, dass wenn, dann fliegen alle Geräte raus, die nur 256 MB Speicher haben. Das wäre dann das iPad 2, das iPhone 4S, der iPod Touch 5. Generation und das iPad Mini.
Das würde dafür sprechen, dass es neue iPods gibt.
Also das wäre so das Logischste.
Ich glaube, die Uhr wird's in vier Jahren noch geben.
Ja, bei Google Glass bin ich mir da nicht so sicher.
Was hat Google eigentlich dieses Jahr vorgestellt?
Dieses Jahr?
Ja, die stellen auch jedes Jahr was vor, was danach total logisch ist.
Das kommt doch immer auf deren Konferenz, die kommt doch erst noch. Wie heißt die Google IO.?
Weiß schon irgendjemand, was sie letztes Jahr angekündigt haben, was total der Hit sein soll? Letztes Mal war das doch...
War das nicht der Music Streaming Service?
Der fünfte?
Ist Glass jetzt schon zwei Jahre her?
Nee, ich glaube letztes Mal haben sie doch diese ominöse neue Telefon-Android A oder wie hieß das? Oder Android G oder B oder L? Android L, genau, diese billige Telefone, diese leicht zu machenden Generic Android-Devices wäre jetzt der nächste Hit.
Naja, eigentlich logisch wäre jetzt so der Android-Hund, der einem folgt. Sie haben ja diese komische Robotik-Bude da gekauft und dann können sie jetzt den Android-Hund rauslegen.
Cool, aber der trägt einem gleich so den Hotspot hinterher.
Da ist genug Platz für deine GSM-Karte.
Genau, der Netzentral hat eine dicke Antenne zur Not, fährt auch noch eine Länge raus, in seinem Schwanz abessen, genau, da macht Sinn.
Und der läuft auch beim Joggen neben dir her und dann kann deine Uhr sich mit dem Hund unterhalten und du brauchst auch kein Telefon mehr am Arm.
Du meinst sowieso der Aibo von Sony?
Vor allem kann der als Davi vorrennen.
So wie der Aibo von Sony, nur halt in funktionierend, also in besser funktionierend, aber immer noch so gut, dass das ein totes Produkt ist.
Weil Google kontert Hey Siri jetzt mit Hey Fifi.
Genau, durch die Kamera, Augen wirst du auch in allen kompromittierenden Lagen die ganze Zeit beobachtet, gefilmt und aufgenommen und so weiter.
Ja, es muss ja auch richtig schon creepy sein, den Leuten so richtig unter die Haut gehen. Also man könnte natürlich dann auch gleich so eine Bulldoggen nehmen oder so. Nicht so ein kleiner Pude.
Genau, Boss Dynamics, so hießen die, hieß die Bude, die sich da einverleiben haben.
Genau, Big Dog.
Genau.
Big Dog, und da gab es jetzt eine neue Variante von Big Dog. Also wir haben mit Big Dog...
Spot, oder?
Big Dog Teil 2. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie heißt der?
Da, das untere Video müsste es sein, Spot.
Spot?
Den ganz rechten kenne ich aber auch noch nicht.
Wahrscheinlich noch. Aber die sehen schon gruselig aus.
Ja, aber es ist schon wirklich...
Läuft aber schon ein bisschen komisch.
Ja, voll stop-motion.
Ist nicht so flüssig. Die sollten sich echt mal so eine Katze als Vorbild nehmen. Das ist schon gemein, aber immer, wenn sie so gegen treten und die Viecher nicht umfallen.
Also das ist wirklich unglaublich. Du kriegst diese Dinger überhaupt nicht mehr außer Balance. Hier in dem Video läuft halt alles möglich. Er läuft über Eisflächen, kriegt einen Tritt von der Seite und legt sich nicht aufs Maul. Er hat ja auch keine. Er legt sich aber auch sonst auf irgendwie keinen Teil. Also die haben schon enorme Fortschritte gemacht. Das ist wirklich total scary. Vor allem ist das Ding jetzt nicht mehr so laut. Ich glaube, die hatten am Anfang sogar einen Verbrennungsmotor drin. Jetzt machen sie das wohl nur noch mit Akkus. Treppe hoch, Treppe runter, alles überhaupt gar kein Problem. Das ist noch nicht so elegant wie Tier, aber das ist auf jeden Fall für Robotik schon wirklich enorm.
Das sieht schon besser aus, so galopp. Das sieht viel geschmeidiger aus jetzt, ne?
Trab ist das.
Oder so.
Trab definiert sich dadurch, dass man zwei Füße gleichzeitig auf dem Boden hat.
Schritt ist immer nur ein Bein, weiter Trab sind immer zwei Beine weiter und galopp ist richtig gesprungen.
Ja, weiß ich nicht.
Soweit ich weiß, wir werden bestimmt wieder korrigiert.
Die können bestimmt auch bald galopp.
Musst du jetzt mal verlinken, oder ist schon, ne? Sonst weiß wieder keiner, was wir gerade gucken hier.
Ja, dann muss ich hier meine Show-Nöte irgendwie.
Oh, der dicke Köter da ist jetzt ganz schön fett, ey. Aber sieht auch nicht besser aus, ist so hakelig irgendwie.
Ja, der war wahrscheinlich noch die erste Version.
Nee, ich glaube, das ist die militärische Version.
Tja, hat sich denn in der Android-Welt irgendwas Interessantes getan?
Ich hab ja letztens, kann ich ja kleine Geschichte erzählen, wir haben ja Zeit für kleine Geschichten, ne? Ein Kumpel hat irgendwie, oder seine Freundin besser gesagt, die haben irgendwie gesehen, dass jemand sein Android-Tablet wegwirft oder irgendwie so. In jeden Fall hat es sich rausgeholt. Das waren Motorola Droid oder Ixo oder wie die heißen.
Wie, da hat einer sein Android-Tablet einfach in den Antennen geschmissen?
Ja, das ist von 2011 gewesen oder so, wir haben mal nachgeguckt. Also das ist schon nicht mehr so das Neueste, muss aber damals das rechts unten Modell gewesen sein. Motorola Droid Ixo oder irgendwie sowas. Und dann hat er versucht einzuschalten, ging natürlich nicht. Dann hat er USB-Rangesteckt, dann hat es so dreimal geblinkt und da ging auch nichts. Auch beide drangelassen, dass einfach nichts passiert. Und dann meinte er, ja, mal auseinandernehmen, gucken, was für eine Batterie drin ist. Und dann kann man ja mal eine neue shoppen. Die können ja nicht so viel kosten. Ich meinte, nee, nee, die Batterie, die ist bestimmt, die können wir reanimieren irgendwie. Ich weiß, dass ich, als ich bei Texter gearbeitet habe, da hatten die glaube ich auch mal Probleme, dass die Ladelektronik irgendwie nicht so richtig aufgepasst hat und die Batterien der Tablets da wurden auch ein bisschen tief entladen und danach gingen die da nicht mehr. Da hat sich die Ladelektronik geweigert, die Batterien wieder aufzuladen. Und dann hat der Stein halt einfach immer seinen Netzteil an die Batterie gehalten für fünf Minuten mit ein bisschen mehr Strom irgendwie. Da hat die Batterie so einen kleinen Anschluss bekommen, so ein bisschen extra Power halt, macht man halt eigentlich nicht. Und danach hat die Ladelektronik die Batterie wieder erkannt, hat die voll geladen und dann waren die wieder gut. Und das hab ich mir gemerkt. Und dann hab ich gesagt, hier, das machen wir da auch so. Haben die Batterie da ausgebaut, haben die ganz normal, ohne überladen, also zu viel Volt, sondern ganz normal in so einem Lithium-Ionen-Akku-Charger irgendwie angeschlossen für eine halbe Stunde. Danach wieder eingebaut, alles schön wieder zusammengebaut. Und zack, ging das Ding wieder. Gleich abgedatet, vorhin noch die Bilder von der Person geguckt, die da vorher drauf waren. War nicht drauf, nicht wirklich. War auch schon wirklich seit einem Jahr nicht in Benutzung. Letztes Jahr Januar oder März oder sowas. Und aber tut wieder. Also man kann, wenn man ein Gerät hat, wo der Lithium-Ionen-Akku irgendwie meint, er ist nicht mehr, oder die Ladeelektronik sagt, hier passiert nichts mehr. Einfach irgendwie ausbauen, direkt irgendwo anschließen, für ein paar Minuten ein bisschen aufpassen, weil ich glaube, das hat ja einen Grund, warum die die Batterie nicht mehr laden wollen. Denn man darf die halt eben tief entladen, ist nicht so gut. Die können dann auch schon mal irgendwie sich ausdehnen oder so. Muss man schon ein bisschen beobachten, die Sache. Und aber wahrscheinlich ist es ganz, nur ein bisschen tief entladen und dann geht's wieder. Und dann tun die Geräte wieder. Muss man keine neuen Akkus kaufen.
Ich hab so ein Ladegerät von Modellbau-Akkus. Der kann ja gewisse Typen laden.
Diese 3,7 Volt, das ist bei Lithium-Ionen, glaube ich, waren es. Oder 3,9, keine Ahnung. Kommt dran auf Protected oder nicht Protected und so, glaube ich. Und ja, dann lädt man die wieder ein bisschen hoch.
Gib ihm!
Aber dieses Motorola-Tablet war ganz schön fett. Irgendwie innen drin, das war gebaut in Panzer, so mit Verstrebungen und so. Also ich glaube, wenn man die von iFixit hier so, die iPad sieht und so, die sehen immer viel dezent aus. Also das war echt, sah ganz schön sehr stabil aus. Ja, das war der kleine Ex-Kurs in die Android-Welt. Bisschen im Moa ist da rumgespielt, aber irgendwie ist es nicht meins. Aber ich glaube, iPads sind auch nicht so meins. Ich konnte mich noch nicht so richtig mit den Dingern anfreunden irgendwie.
Ja, meine Oma freundet sich immer mehr mit dem iPad an, das ich ihr vermacht habe. Das ist wirklich...
Lass uns mal über was ganz anderes reden. Für die Freunde der koffeinhaltigen Kaltgetränke. Koffeinhaltige Kaltgetränke. Habe ich neulich etwas entdeckt, genial. Heißt Kreuzbeer und ist Fassbrause mit Koffein drin. Schmeckt unglaublich geil. Also dafür würde ich jede Mate stehen lassen.
Und wo sind die Probeflächen?
Ja, wird in Berlin produziert. Zumindest sitzt die Firma irgendwie in Kreuzberg, in der Greifestraße. Weiß nicht, ob die da auch produzieren. Ja, quasi. Hab ich da beim Getränke-Hopfmann entdeckt und dachte mir, ach das Label, das sieht aber nett aus. Das ist so ein Berliner Bär, der sich halt gerade sowas hinter die Binde kippt. Ja, kann man mal machen.
Ja und Link?
Link hab ich nicht.
Wie heißt das?
Kreuzbär.
Wie schreist du das?
Na wie Kreuz und wie Bär. Bär, das Tier.
Kreuzbär. Fassbrause. kreuzbär.de. Das war ja einfach. In so einer Astra-Bottle.
Genau, in so einer Astra-Bottle. Das ist auch genau so die richtige Menge, die man mal so zwischendrin zischen kann.
Fassbrause für Berliner Schnauzen. Supergeil. Das hat es noch nie gegeben. Kreuzbär, Fassbrause ist die erste Fassbrause aus Berlin. Kreuzberg. Geboren im Brau aus Südstern. Wer mehr gibt, Berliner wird nicht, oder was. Hier nur so paar Worte, oder was.
Also ich finde die total lecker. Vor allen Dingen die ist auch nicht so brutal süß wie andere Fassbrausen.
Warum, also was ich jetzt geil gefunden hätte, wenn diese Webseite oben noch so ein Language-Flag gehabt hätte, wo man Deutsch und Berlinerisch umschalten kann. Da war ich nämlich jetzt gestern total überrascht, wenn du nämlich auf die Webseite vom FC Bayern gehst, FC Bayern München, was man ja so häufig nicht macht, gibt es tatsächlich diese Webseite in Deutsch, in US-Amerikanisch, in Englisch, also es ist wirklich normalerweise heißt ja immer nur eine der beiden Flangen, aber sie haben offensichtlich explizit so eine Portalfunktion, wie ein Amerikaner auf den FC Bayern blickt und wie ein Britter auf Dingsfragen, dann Japanisch, sagt eine Menge aus über diese Zielmärkte, dann Spanisch, etwas weniger überraschend, Chinesisch, fand ich jetzt auch schon bemerkenswert, kommt aber noch krasser, Russisch, dann Arabisch, okay, ich meine, die haben ja auch ihre Freunde da in Saudi-Arabien, und knaller, Bayrisch. Die Spielzusammenfassung ist halt so haben wir gespielt.
Moistasammer, das ist sowas.
Ja, also Kreuzbär könnte sozusagen auch überlegen, ob da nicht vielleicht auch nochmal was in Berlinerisch angemessen wäre. Vielleicht auch was für Freak Show FM.
Das ist aber auch ein schlimmes Bayrisch.
Ja, aber so ist das halt immer.
Wieso, gibt es das auch irgendwie anders?
Naja, das ist so unglaublich aufgetragen.
Das ist Bayrisch.
Ja, so ist das halt.
Ja, aber man muss, nee.
Ist halt wie im Fernsehen Berlinern, so ein bisschen over-the-top.
Ihr seid für Fußball nicht so zugänglich, was?
Doch, ich hab's gesehen, aber ich fand das Spiel ein bisschen anstrengend, ehrlich gesagt.
Das ist wirklich ein Spiel, was ich denn für die nächsten zwei Jahre auf Repeat anschaue. Wir haben ja vor zwei Wochen dieses Werther gespielt, Bayern gegen Porto, und dann haben wir geguckt und dann haben sie auch gesagt, es wäre ein voll wichtiges Spiel, und ich im Klub, wie steht's dann so, dann gucken wir 3-0, dann guckt der andere, meint er, ne wir 0, ich guck schon fast wieder in der 5-0, dann haben wir gedacht, ok, da braucht man ja eigentlich nix mehr gucken, und dann haben wir über so Fußballspiele geredet, die man guckt, obwohl man kein Fan ist, und dann meinte ich, na, ich hab ja hier immer, damit es mir gut geht, dieses Brasilien-Spiel auf meinem Rechner, hab ich angemacht, hatte halbe Club kurz irgendwie das gegen Brasilien-Spiel geschaut, und das ist einfach immer wieder diese fünf oder zehn Minuten da, wo die Tore da so fallen wie...
Wobei Bayern gegen Porto war ja im Prinzip noch mal genau das gleiche, da stand es ja auch 5-0.
Ja, aber das hatte ich nicht als HD-Stream auf meinem Rechner mit BBC-Kommentar, weil der bringt es nämlich.
Ich finde auch, ich lese halt tatsächlich auch, wenn ich, also ich bin ja relativ neutraler Fußball-Konnaisseur, sagen wir mal, also wenn es ein gutes Spiel ist, finde ich es gut. Egal welcher Verein da jetzt spielt und ich gucke halt öfters mal beim Guardian in die Fußball-Sektion, also hier die englische Zeitung. Die haben ja auch, ist ja geil, bei den englischen Zeitungen, da gibt es dann Sport und Football, das ist oft auch eine eigene Sektion und das Schöne ist, beim Britisch-Englisch, die haben einfach ein viel schöneres Vokabular. Da wird sehr viel elaborierter und sehr viel im Detail über so Ereignisse berichtet. Deswegen finde ich es auch ganz schön, dass die Bayern, Britisch, Englisch und Amerikanisch, weil wahrscheinlich immer Amerikanisch und es ist alles awesome und so like, great and amazing.
Also ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ich habe es mir nicht so genau angeschaut um festzustellen, ob sie jetzt wirklich das Englisch angepasst haben oder ob es nur so ein Blick ist, so ein typischer Premier League Blick auf, also weil ich meine ein Britter hat natürlich einen ganz anderen Zugang zu Fußball als ein Amerikaner.
Und aber wie gesagt, auch, ja das müssen wir mal prüfen, ob sie auch sprachlich da wirklich mitgehen, aber ich finde auf jeden Fall Britisch, Englisch, Britisch, Englisch immer wieder schön zu lesen und zu hören, weil die einfach vokabularmäßig sehr viel mehr abgehen und elaborierter. Das ist irgendwie, da merkt man erstmal, dass Englisch eigentlich doch sehr auch facettenreich sein kann. Weil wenn man die ganze Zeit nur so amerikanische Serien und so weiter konsumiert, dann kriegt man manchmal den Eindruck, dass es alles nur awesome und like und amazing und great und...
Es ist eine Tat, eine Wohltat, das merke ich auch gerade. Also in Bristol wird da sehr angenehmes Englisch gesprochen. Es ist halt auch so ein bisschen so eine Middle Class Stadt, das macht sicherlich auch nochmal was aus. Aber es wird halt sehr viel mehr auch über die Melodie gearbeitet als jetzt über dieses Kaula-Belch, diese amerikanische Kaugummi-Variante, die ist auch immer so ein bisschen merkwürdig. Also ich hab immer sowieso das Gefühl, wenn man das Wort like verbieten würde, dann hätten die schon fast nichts mehr zu sagen. Naja, aber wir wollen ja kein Amerika-Bashing machen.
So, ich könnte jetzt hier die Kurve drehen von der Fassbrause.
Dreh die Kurve von der Fassbrause.
Wobei die Bristol Rovers gerade in den Tor geschossen haben. Das steht 1 zu 0.
Zu einem Bier und zu einem Restaurant, das würde so passen.
Genau, das finde ich nämlich auch. Wir können mal wieder in die Technik einsteigen, denn Dennis...
Was Bier und Restaurant? Wir können in die Technik einsteigen.
Ja, aber erstmal muss ich das Bier, das kommt vorne ran, weil wir gerade bei dem Getränk da waren, und zwar war ich in dem besagten Restaurant, über das wir dann danach reden, und da kam gerade der Dienstleister an, der die Bierzapfanlage reinigen muss. Und da dachte ich mal, so Sendung mit der Maus mäßig, jetzt bleibst du mal hier und guckst dir das mal an. Und erstens, der muss alle zwei Wochen kommen, ist vorgeschrieben, muss man machen, manche machen es sogar öfter, aber Minimum zwei Wochen, und der kommt dann mit so einem kleinen Kasten mit Eingang, Ausgang und eigentlich hat der sogar vier Anschlüsse. Jedenfalls ist das so eine Art Kreislauf, der wird einmal oben an den Zapfhahn angeschlossen, dann unten am Fass und dann spült er da durch und dann sind aber zusätzlich noch so kleine Schwammkügelchen drin, die werden da auch durchgespült, die sorgen dafür, dass das so ein bisschen lang kratzt und die Reststoffe da sich entfernen, weil da bleibt in den Rohren drin.
Also wie so ein Kugelhaufenreaktor.
Nee, das ist so eine kleine weiche Schwammkugel, die da so durchgedrückt wird durch Druck. Und der Kasten, den er mitbringt, diese kleinen Pumpe sozusagen, die sorgt dafür, dass die Kügelchen sich in so einem Kreislauf bewegen, dass das Wasser aber trotzdem ausgetauscht wird. Also das ist sozusagen so ein Nebenanschluss, der Wasser reinpumpt und auch wieder absaugt und die Kügelchen aber trotzdem immer hier durch die Zapfanlage durchgedreht wird und dann kann er mit so einem Schalter auch noch die Richtung verändern, weil falls die Kügelchen immer irgendwo hängen bleiben, dass sie immer so hin und her gehen dann irgendwie und das macht er dann sozusagen mit allen Zapfinnen, die so da sind.
Amazing!
Ja, so und dann hat er mir gezeigt, dass auch nach zwei Wochen, weil er kommt ja alle zwei Wochen, hat er einen so einen Zapfan auseinander genommen, da war da tatsächlich so ein weißlicher Schleim, sah so ein bisschen aus wie so eine weiße Creme irgendwie, so halb durchsichtig aber eigentlich schon noch weiß und ich habe mal dran gerochen, das roch sehr säuerlich und das ist das, was halt da drin bleibt in den in den Bierleitungen, wenn man halt nur schon nach zwei Wochen irgendwie reinigt und da habe ich noch was gelernt und zwar was ein Nachtwächterbier ist. Wisst ihr was ein Nachtwächterbier ist?
Keine Ahnung.
Das ist das Bier, was als wenn der der Kneipier oder die Bar, wenn die aufmacht morgens oder wann auch immer die aufmachen, das erste Bier, was aus der Leitung kommt, was sozusagen die ganze Nacht in den Leitungen ist, Standard, das ist das Nachtwächterbier und eine ordentliche Kneipe, die schüttet das weg, weil das ist halt abgestanden. Es gibt wohl aber auch Leute, meint er zu mir, die mögen das Nachtwächterbier und trinken das gerne, weil das halt, ja zum Beispiel durch die Reste, die da nicht ganz, wenn es ein bisschen älter ist, die Leitung halt, so zwei Wochen max, weil es halt ein bisschen säuerlicher schmeckt. Gibt es halt so Fans, aber also das, was ich da gehochen hab, war auch nicht schlimm, das roch nicht modrig oder sonstiges, es roch nur säuerlich, also es ist ja nach zwei Wochen, so viel kann da jetzt ja auch nicht passieren, aber das ist halt das Nachtwächterbier. Ja, das war schon das, so und das Ganze fand statt in einem Restaurant in der Torstraße, das heißt Friedel Richter, ist auch relativ neu, ich glaube, die haben Ende letzten Jahres auch gemacht.
In Berlin-Mitte?
In Berlin-Mitte, ja, wir sind ja hier Berliner, war bei mir um die Ecke sozusagen, zwei Ecken und da bin ich mit auch einem aus dem Club am Basteln auch seit letztem Jahr, Ende letztes Jahr, und zwar haben die sich vom Wiener Flughafen, das war im Wiener Flughafen, stand da schon eine Weile im Keller, haben die sich ein 5 Meter breites, 2 Meter hohes Flip-Dot-Display gekauft und haben das da mit Holzbalken, weil die Wand hätte nicht gereicht irgendwie, da haben sie die Holzbalken verstärkt irgendwie, haben die das da an die Wand gehängt und das hängt jetzt da und das hätte auch so wie unser Display im Club, glaube ich, ja so, weiß nicht, auch so ein Mikrocontroller aus den 80ern gehabt, so eine CPU irgendwie, weiß nicht, ob das auch ein 6502 war, aber was so in der Richtung wahrscheinlich auch über seriell gesteuert und nur ASCII und sonst gar nichts und stinkend langsam, haben wir uns gar nicht weiter mit beschäftigt, sondern auch wie im Club das gleich alles weggeschmissen, haben da ein Beagle-Bone rangeklatscht mit irgendwie so einer Adapter-Platine, weil Beagle-Bone macht 3,3 Volt und dieses Display braucht sogar 12 Volt, nicht mal 5, sondern 12 Volt Technik war das alles.
Was für die Elektronik, oder jetzt um das Display selber zu steuern?
Die Elektromechanik.
Die Logikchips sozusagen, normalerweise du kennst ja schon auch diese 74 tralala irgendwas, so und und oder-Gatter, das sind immer 5 Volt TML, wie man das so kennt, das ist aber halt noch ein bisschen älter oder aus anderen Gönnen, jedenfalls das war alles 12 Volt. Da heißt der Chip dann nämlich nicht 74 15, sondern heißt dann 40 15, das ist dann 12 Volt. Jetzt kommen wieder die Spezial-Profis, die das irgendwie noch ein Stück besser wissen, weiß ich nicht, ist egal. Das ist auf jeden Fall mit 12 Volt und dann haben wir jetzt so eine Adapter-Platinie, die aus den 3,3 Volt-Signalen von Beagle-Bone irgendwie 12 Volt-Signale machen und noch ein bisschen Logik und einen Watch-Dock haben wir eingebaut, damit irgendwie da die Spulen dieser Flip-Dots nicht durchknallen, wenn man denen zu lange Strom gibt, dann wird es nämlich scheiße heiß. Das ist dann sozusagen auch die, ist ja auch wie Induktion dann oder? Wenn die warm werden, ist das ja gleich wie bei unserem Kochfeld vorhin, richtig? Magnetspule irgendwie, so ein Metallstift in der Mitte, der wird dann richtig heiß.
Ja, es ist halt einfach. Draht, Strom, Widerstand macht Wärme, also es ist irgendwie, das hat jetzt weniger was mit Induktion zu tun.
Nee, einfach mit Stromfluss hat das zu tun. Aber bevor du da zutage gehst, vielleicht erklärst du nochmal generell Flip-Dot-Display. Also jeder kennt ja LED-Displays und man kennt auch insbesondere aus Bahnhöfen und Flughäfen im Prinzip ja zwei mechanische Anzeigetafeln. Das eine sind diese durchfallenden...
Faltblattanzeigen.
So heißen die? Faltblatt?
So eine habe ich bisher noch nicht gehabt. Ich glaube die heißen Faltblattanzeigen.
So etwas habe ich mal nachprogrammiert.
Faltblattanzeige, ich finde da jetzt gerade nichts.
Ja, die alten Faltblattanzeigen haben ausgedient. Ja, ich denke schon, dass die so heißen. Ja, aber das ist halt eben keine Faltblattanzeige, sondern ein Flip-Dot. Das funktioniert so, da ist eine quadratische Fläche, also in meinem Fall, es gibt auch welche, die ein bisschen anders aussehen, quadratische Fläche, die auf der Diagonalen an den Enden so kleine Scharniere haben, wo so ein dreieckiges Plättchen drin hängt, was sozusagen auch entweder auf die eine Seite von dem Quadrat kippen kann oder auf die andere.
Es klappt so diagonal runter?
Genau, es kann so diagonal auf die eine Seite von dem Quadrat klappen oder auf die andere. Sozusagen die eine Hälfte von dem Quadrat abgedeckt, also so diagonal, oder die andere Hälfte.
Ja, und eine ist schwarz und die andere ist weiß, ne?
Genau, und das Quadrat ist auch, auf einem Dreieck ist es halt schon weiß. Und wenn es dann so aufgeklappt ist, dann ist auf der Seite natürlich das Plastikdreieckchen da auch weiß. Und wenn das Plastikdreieckchen so umklappt, dann sind beide Seiten schwarz. So macht man das. So, und damit dieses Plastikdreieckchen, damit das so umklappen kann, ist da so ein ganz kleiner Magnet auf einer von beiden Seiten. Und unter dem Plastik, unter dem Viereck sozusagen, da ist eine Spule, die man halt in beide Richtungen Strom durchjagen kann. Das heißt, entweder die zieht den Magneten an oder sie stößt ihn ab. Und je nachdem würde da oben das Plastikdreieckchen dann auch so abgestoßen werden, umklappen und auf der anderen Seite natürlich dann automatisch angezogen werden, weil der Magnet hat sich ja umgeklappt. Und so kann man da halt den Pixel sozusagen ein- und ausschalten. Und davon hat dieses Display da halt 325 x 84 von diesen kleinen Plastikdreieckchen. Und wenn du das ganze Display halt so befeuerst, dann rasselt das so lang, weil dieses Umklappen der kleinen Dreieckchen macht natürlich auch Lärm, weil die bewegen ein bisschen Luft. Das ist jetzt eher nicht Lärm, aber sie klappen halt um und das klatscht dann halt da so rauf und die rascheln dann so.
Bistabiles Anzeigeelement.
Genau, das ist der Vorteil, weil egal, wie rum das Plättchen da angezogen wird, wenn man dann den Strom von dem ganzen Display ausmacht, dann bleibt alles so, wie es ist. Das heißt, du kannst einmal was anzeigen lassen, machst aus und dann bleibt das halt so. Und man kann sogar, ich habe extra...
Das heißt, machst aus. Also eigentlich müsste ja auch gar kein Strom fließen, wenn kein Update erfolgt.
Ja, fließt nicht, aber hinter den ganzen Spulen und so weiter. Du musst ja auch Elektronik haben, damit die Spulen wissen, also du musst die Spulen ja steuern und welche gerade dran ist und so weiter. Hast du ja lauter Serial-Shifter und Voltage-Converter, die halt von 24 Volt auf 12 Volt gehen und das Signalverstärker und Serial-Buffer, Hex-Buffer und Hexen-Verted-Buffer und so weiter und so fort. Und die brauchen ja alle irgendwie ein bisschen Strom. Und davon sind da halt, weiß nicht, was wir ausgerechnet haben, aber auch locker über 1000 Chips da drin oder so oder 700. Ich weiß gar nicht so genau. Und die verbrauchen, selbst wenn sie alle nichts tun, 120 Watt.
Also eigentlich bräuchte die Elektronik so eine Abschaltmethode, dass wenn man keine Updates holt, dass sie sich einfach richtig abschalten.
Das haben wir da noch nicht, das kommt aber noch. Also dann wird der Beagle-Bohn Dauerstrom kriegen und wird dann über so ein kleines Relais die großen 24 Volt-Netzteile dann einfach an- und ausschalten.
Der kann ja dann sagen, wenn jetzt seit so und so viel Sekunden nichts gekommen ist, dann fährt das einfach runter und dann fährt das halt wieder hoch.
Haben wir im Club auch so bei unserem LED-Display, da haben wir jetzt ein Timeout von einer Viertelstunde. Wenn du eine Viertelstunde keine Movies oder sonst irgendwas hinsendest, dann geht's aus. Aber im Gegensatz zum Flip-Dot-Display im Club, wenn wir da so eine normale Anzeige haben, z.B. in unserem Datengarten machen wir das immer, dass wir alle Informationen da immer so anzeigen, nach einer Viertelstunde sind die Anzeigen oder die Daten dann auch weg, weil das sind ja LEDs, die sind ja dann aus. Und beim Flip-Dot-Display, dann wäre wenigstens die Tageskarte, die wir so anzeigen und sein Menü, was er da anzeigt, das bleibt wenigstens alles da. Das heißt, da kann man schon entspannt ausschalten.
Aber das ist jetzt kein durchgehende Matrix, sondern das sind immer so einzelne Charakters?
Genau, das sind sozusagen in Buchstaben aufgeteilt, die so einen Rahmen haben, könnte man sagen. Und die Buchstaben haben fünf mal sieben Pixel. Und dann kommt irgendwie nach rechts zwei Pixel, wo halt Rahmen ist und dann kommt der nächste Buchstabe und nach unten sind sogar drei.
Also nicht Buchstaben, sondern so Orte, wo Buchstabe erscheinen kann. Also immer so kleine Pixel-Inseln sozusagen.
Genau, so wie bei dem Wikipedia-Artikel hier.
Wie stabiles Anzeigen-Element.
Genau, das erste Bild. So ähnlich muss man sich das vorstellen.
Plus da ist ja der Zwischenrand bei dieser 0,31, damit alle auch sehen, dass sie beim richtigen sind. Oder was heißt 0,31? Space 31, müsste man sagen. Da ist zwischen denen ja... Und das ist genau auch dieser Dreieck, weil sonst die meisten Anzeigelemente, die sind immer rundlich, die funktionieren ein bisschen anders auch. Und das ist aber genau das, woran wir da basteln. Und hier kann man die Dreiecke so schön sehen. Und auch den Magneten in der Mitte sieht man hier eigentlich auch ganz schön. Dieses ganz kleine, quadratische Ding, was da in der Mitte hängt. Und ja, da mussten wir auch einen extra einen Font irgendwie besorgen, der halt fünfmal sieben groß ist. Den hatten wir dann auch auf dem Rechner. Den gibt's. Der ist irgendwie bei X irgendwie mit dabei. Aber der ist natürlich so designt, dass wie auf deinem Bildschirm, da ist natürlich dein Buchstabe direkt, also du hast ja keinen Rand zwischen deinen Pixeln, sondern du musst sozusagen deine Leerlinie musst du halt mit einberechnen. Deswegen, wenn du einen Font hast, der fünfmal sieben groß ist, dann benutzt du eigentlich nur vier Spalten. Weil er eine Leerspalt hat, weil er sich ja vom nächsten Buchstaben abtrennt. Das muss man da nicht machen. Dann muss man doch erstmal uns noch irgendwie andere Fonts angucken und besorgen und haben dann irgendwie von so einem Chip irgendwie uns den geklaut und den aber noch optimiert, weil der war irgendwie scheiße. Die acht war zum Beispiel, die ging irgendwie einfach nur so gerade runter außen.
Aber euer Beagle-Bohn, vielleicht kannst du noch mal Christi, also ihr habt jetzt einen Beagle-Bohn ran gemacht, der sozusagen die ganze Steuerung übernimmt. Und dazu gibt es dann noch diese ganze diskrete Elektronik, die jetzt eigentlich nichts anderes macht, als die Signale an den richtigen Pixel zu lenken.
Ja, das ist alles schon da. Das Ding hat auch so eine Art Zeilen-Controller, könnte man sagen, die halt alle mit einem so einem Flachbandkabel verbunden sind. Und das ist alles weit an das Original. Und auch die Panels selbst, wo halt die Flip-Dots drauf sind, das ist alles alte Technik. Aber die Steuereinheit sozusagen, das ist jetzt das Beagle-Bohn.
Ja gut, aber ich wollte jetzt darauf hinaus, was ist die Abstraktion, die ihr mit dem Beagle-Bohn seht? Also auf welchem Level kommuniziert ihr? Was sagt ihr dieser Elektronik? Gibt es da eine Adressierung? Muss sozusagen, dass du sagst, ich will hier XY so und so haben? Oder musst du das komplette Timing machen und dann auch was durchlaufen lassen?
Nee, Timing musst du schon machen, du bestimmst das schon. Die Zeilenkontrolle haben alle eine ID. Die sind über so kleine DIP-Schalter irgendwie durchnummeriert. Das sind sechs Stück, die immer zwei Zeilen versorgen, also insgesamt zwölf Zeilen. Die adressierst du, indem du auf der Leitung halt vier, fünf Bits hast und dann sagst du, jetzt spreche ich Zeile 0 an, jetzt spreche ich Zeile 1 an und so weiter. Und während du das machst, schickst du dann deine Daten. Also sagst du irgendwie Zeile 0, folgende Daten, Zeile 1, folgende Daten, Zeile 2, folgende Daten. Also machst du sozusagen eine Spalte von oben nach unten durch. Dann haben alle Zeilenkontroller ihre Daten und dann sagst du, jetzt rausschieben. Nur für eine Spalte dann? Für eine Spalte und zwar auch nur die gesamte Spalte.
Das heißt, du kannst nicht eine Spalte das ganze zeichnen, nicht nur eine.
Nee, eine Spalte, ein Pixel breit.
Ein Pixel, okay.
Genau und dann sagst du, rausschieben und dann schiebt das an die Stelle raus, die Spalte, die gerade aktiv ist. Und das Display weiß, welche Spalte aktiv ist, indem sozusagen alle Spalten sind an Serial Shifter angeschlossen. Und in die Serial Shifter schickst du einfach so ein Bit rein und da, wo das Bit gerade ist, die Spalte ist aktiv.
Das heißt, du kannst direkt vom Billi-Bron, im Prinzip jedes Bit direkt ansprechen. Es gibt jetzt keinen Character Set oder so, in den du einmal reinlegst und so. Das heißt, das ist voll Bit adressierbar und du kannst im Prinzip jedes beliebige Bild anzeigen.
Korrekt. Aber du kannst nur spaltenweise updaten.
Und wie lange dauert das so, einmal updaten von links nach rechts?
Schon so eine Sekunde.
Für die ganzen fünf Meter? Eine Sekunde alles?
Ja, es sind 325 Spalten, die du da so lang fährst. Vielleicht ist es sogar ein bisschen mehr als eine Sekunde inzwischen. Wir müssen am Timing noch ein bisschen drehen. Wir dachten auch, wir haben gehofft, dass es ein bisschen mehr ist, dass man so auf zwei, drei oder vier, fünf, sechs Frames die Sekunde kommt, aber es geht einfach nicht. Dann haut das Timing nicht mehr hin und dann kriegst du Pixelfehler und so weiter und so fort.
Und wenn man jetzt nur einen Teil updaten muss man trotzdem aber immer alles, man muss immer durch jede Spalte durchgehen oder kann man im Prinzip immer nicht anders mit dieser Spalte anfangen?
Das machen wir jetzt schon anders. Wenn man jetzt Text reinschickt und sagen wir mal, dein Text ist, Anna, fängt erst beim fünften Zeichen an, dann kann man mit diesem Civil-Shifter, man überspringt die ersten Spalten einfach und hüpft da dran ganz schnell vorbei, sodass da nichts passiert. Und dann schickt man den kompletten Inhalt ab dem fünften Zeichen, also die gesamte Spalte, also auch da wo man eigentlich nichts schreiben will, da muss man halt aus seinem Buffer, den du in deinem Bitmap-Buffer, den hast, den alten Content nochmal schicken, weil das updatest du dann alles und wenn du dann fertig bist und du bist noch nicht am Ende, dann hörst du einfach auf und den Rest schreibst du dann auch nicht. Also du kannst schon...
Das heißt, ihr könntet eigentlich den kompletten Inhalt sowieso im Speicher vorhalten, werdet ihr immer schon eh tun. Und dann einfach immer nur einen Diff machen quasi. Also das ist so double buffert Arbeit. Du hast so einen Buffer mit, das soll es jetzt werden. Du rennst quasi den Font in den neuen Buffer und du hast einen zweiten Buffer, der den Ist-Zustand repräsentiert und dann machst du einen Diff und gehst einfach nur noch an die Spalten und die Pixel ran, die einen Diff haben. Dann hast du auch eigentlich die maximale Abwechslung.
Spalten kann man ja nur komplett machen. Das heißt, wenn in der ganzen Spalte auch nur ein Pixel anders ist, dann musst du die ganze Spalte machen.
Oft wird sich ja vielleicht auch die ganze Spalte nicht geändert haben.
Ja, das könnte man so machen, das haben wir aber so noch nicht. Aber wenn man Text schreibt an bestimmten Stellen nur, dann macht das auch nur an den Spalten, wo sich was geändert hat und der Rest bleibt so, wie er ist. Das haben wir schon.
Aber wenn du also irgendwas schnell machen willst, dann wäre das quasi so, also wenn du jetzt so einen Sprite haben willst, der sich schnell bewegt, dann wäre das effizienteste in der Y-Bewegung von oben nach unten, weil du dann eben was mit einem einzigen Update machen kannst.
Na und wenn er sich ganz langsam zur Seite bewegt, dann geht's auch, weil das ist ja eigentlich nur eine Spalte mehr. Er wandert eine Spalte nach rechts, dann musst du hinter ihm eine weglöschen.
Aber da könntest du ja Pong machen, und zwar indem man Pong von oben nach oben spielt.
Nee, links, rechts würde auch gehen. Der kleine Ball, das sind ja dann nur sechs, sieben Spalten, das geht schon.
Das wär ne Leistung.
Das würde gehen.
Wie das klingt.
Pac-Man.
Aber es wär geil. Also Pong wär...
Naja, stimmt, auch immer nur da an einer Stelle, wo er wandert. Entweder wandert er links, rechts oder nach oben und dann ändert sich auch nicht viel.
Der Rest der Schlange bleibt ja, der macht vorne ran und hinten weg.
Was gibt's noch so an Nokia Games? Tetris ist von oben nach unten in der Regel ne Bewegung. Die links-rechts Bewegungen sind wenig und dann hast du halt auch die anderen nicht mehr.
Ja, es hat halt nur 12 Zeilen, da wird es irgendwann noch ein bisschen dünn.
Also Pong ist schon...
Ja, aber auch Tetris von links nach rechts. Gut, ist nicht so sexy. Aber du hast ja immer nur sehr wenig, wo sich was ändert.
Breakout würde auch gehen, ja.
Weil du hast viel Breite und kannst... Ist halt langsamer Frame Rate, aber geht schon. Pong ist halt der Klassiker, ja.
Da müssen wir aber auch an unser Pixel-Engine noch ein bisschen drehen dann für Pong.
Ja, und vor allem müsste man halt überlegen, was das Interaktionsmodell ist. Also mit was steuert man dann sozusagen? Also müsste man dann quasi noch eine iOS-App...
Du hast halt zwei Joysticks an den beiden Bar in.
Cool, so und was ist jetzt das Interface zum Beaglebone hin?
Also wie kommt man da ran? Na, das Beaglebone hat ja Ethernet. Und der Besitzer hat zuerst, hat dann ein Web-Interface bekommen, wo er einzelne Zeilen ans Display schicken konnte, wo er sagen konnte, in welcher Zeile und in welcher Spalte sein Text kommen sollte. Und inzwischen hat er auch für sein Windows, der hat ein Windows irgendwie, hat da so eine Art Droplets, wie auch immer, so Programmchen bekommen, auf die man halt ein Bild oder ein Text feilen lassen kann. Und das Bild wird dann konvertiert auf die Größe. Und ich glaube, wird es auch automatisch monochrom gemacht. Weiß ich gar nicht, ob das Bild schon fertig sein muss, aber es schickt jedenfalls das Bild in und zeigt das ganze Bitmap auf dem Display an. Und bei dem anderen Droplet-Dings, da kann er sein Text drauf feilen lassen und dann wird der Text irgendwie dementsprechend auf dem Display anbezeigt.
Da müsste er ja im Prinzip die Abstände zwischen den Zeilen auch noch mit berücksichtigen.
Ja, das haben wir auch noch nicht. Im Club machen wir das schon, wenn wir da Videos abspielen, dass die Zwischenzeilen, also als wenn da was über dem Film drüber liegen würde und der Film aber eigentlich die komplette Größe hat, so wie er ist. Und bei dem Display, weil das aber in zwei Dimensionen diese Spalten hat, ist es ein bisschen komplexer. Das haben wir noch nicht. Das müsste man aber auch noch machen.
Weil der Zeilenabstand größer ist als der Inter-Buchstabenabstand sozusagen. Also die einzelnen Lettern haben nur einmal einen Pixel, quasi tote Spalter.
Ja, ne, von links nach rechts sind es glaube ich zwei Pixel dazwischen tot. Also in dem Beispiel ist es nur einer. Bei dem Display sind es halt zwei und nach unten sind es sogar drei. Und weil der Abstand halt auch nicht gleich ist, ist es nicht gleichmäßig auseinandergezogen. Das heißt, auch wenn man jetzt schon Bilder raufschiebt, dann wirken die so ein bisschen verzerrt in eine Dimension. Und sieht immer ein bisschen komisch aus. Aber das sind noch so, das ist jetzt alles nur noch so Software. Und eigentlich auch eher beim beim Senden, wo man das berücksichtigen muss auf dem Board selbst, ist jetzt eigentlich, muss man fast gar nichts mehr machen.
Wie viele Pixel hast du jetzt nach oben und unten?
Also eine Breite 325, das sind 65 Zeichen mit 5 Pixel Breite. Das sind 325, genau. Und in der Höhe sind es 12 Zeilen mal 7 Pixel. Und das sind 27.300 Flip-Dots.
Also nochmal Y, von oben nach unten.
12 mal 7.
12 mal 7 plus, und jetzt würde ich...
Wieso plus, mal?
Nein, also 12 mal 7, in Klammern, plus, und jetzt will ich diese virtuellen, nicht wirklich existenten Pixel dazurechnen. Ach so, naja, 3. 3 mal 11.
Kann man so sagen, ja.
Und in X hast du jetzt, wie viel?
65 mal 5, da müsstest du plus 64 mal 2.
So, weil daraus kriegst du ja dann quasi so eine virtuelle Pixelauflösung, da müsstest du jedes Bild nur da drauf zoomen.
Ja, und dann die Sachen nicht schicken.
Genau.
Und die weglassen. Genau. Beim Club machen wir das so, und danach, beim Filme gucken, das sah ein bisschen verzerrt aus. Besonders wenn du so seitwärts oder so Kamerafahrt machst, die so über die Landschaft schwenken, so seitwärts halt oder so leicht hochgehen dabei, dann sah das immer ein bisschen komisch aus im Club. Und nachdem wir das repariert haben, dann war das alles schick. Wenn du weit genug weg sitzt, dann hast du einfach nur das Gefühl, da liegt halt irgendwie so ein Streifen über dem Film, und das stört dann gar nicht mehr. Das macht dann gehören automatisch weg.
Ich finde das ja saugeil. Und was sucht ihr noch an, sucht ihr noch Content?
Also noch ist es sozusagen nicht freigegeben, sozusagen für die Besucher, dass die da auch was machen können, aber irgendwie sowas in die Richtung müssen wir schon machen. Weil ich habe dem auch schon gesagt, man macht Content eigentlich nicht selber, weil es ja viel zu anstrengend, sondern man sorgt dafür, dass andere das machen. Also so wie, meine Beispiele waren Facebook und Twitter und so, die machen ja den Content nicht selber. Die leben ja davon, dass die User den machen. Und das muss bei seinem Display eigentlich auch so sein. Seine Gäste sollen halt Content machen oder der Content muss so automatisch entstehen. Der Koch kann ja nicht die ganze Zeit an seinem Rechner da rumflicken und da irgendwie Sachen aufs Display zaubern. Deswegen kann zum Beispiel sein Bestellsystem, was er da hat, kann theoretisch auch die Bestellungen aufs Display zaubern. Da muss man halt gar nichts mehr machen. Dann hat das so ein bisschen so ein Eigenleben. So ein Display macht ja erst Spaß, wenn es Sachen von selber macht. Und in die Richtung war immer glaube ich ein bisschen. Deswegen muss es irgendwie Content sein, wo der Koch nichts machen muss.
Genau und vor allem, was ja hier auch noch eine interessante Herausforderung ist, was ist Content, der im Kontext eines Restaurants angemessen ist? Also was könnte cool genug sein, dass es irgendwie dem Ambiente des Restaurants so was Cooles gibt, was aber nicht nervt? Weil wenn da jetzt die ganze Zeit was, weiß ich, live oder sowas ablaufen würde, ist es irgendwie auf der einen Seite erst mal langweilig, pointless.
Und zweitens scheiße laut.
Und zweitens scheiße laut. Sondern du willst eigentlich was haben, was dich immer wieder mal zum Hinschauen anregt, was du dann witzig findest.
Wie viele Liter Bier getrunken werden?
Statistik meinst du?
Eine Variante.
Ja, weiß nicht, ob das so spannend ist, auch was du gerade geordert hast oder ob es gleich fertig ist.
Man könnte jetzt so einen rein grafisch spielerischen generativen Ansatz natürlich wählen, dass man sagt, da ist jetzt irgendwie Blumenwiese und da passiert sowas über die Zeit. Keine Ahnung, bildet sich da irgendwas heraus, was weiß ich, wächst Schimmel? Muss ja auch monochrom gut darstellbar sein, gut erkennbar sein. Das wäre so das eine. Das andere ist, dass man eher sagt, okay, das ist ja ohnehin ein klassisches Dashboard. Das ist so eine Anzeige von Vorgängen, Flughafen-Feeling eben, Abflugzeit etc. Was weiß ich, es gibt nur noch fünfmal den Nachtisch oder...
Der nächste Bus fährt in zehn Minuten.
Es gibt ja auch diese Bierbörsen. Ist wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen schlimm, aber vielleicht könnte man sich da was angenehmeres...
Eine Essensbörse, das letzte Steak und dann steigt so ein Preis. Man kann es ja nicht nur mit Bier machen, man kann es ja mit allen Sachen machen.
Genau, dass man schon so einen so dynamischen...
Ich glaube, das wählen sie vielleicht als Restaurant, aber auch nicht, dass du sagst, das muss raus.
Du musst das ja nicht immer machen. Man könnte ja dann so einen speziellen Abend machen, wo dann nur Nerds kommen, die...
Gammeliges Fleisch essen können.
Nö, ich meine, dass man auch so einen speziellen Event daraus macht, dass man sagt, heute werden die Preise irgendwie anders definiert oder die Verfügbarkeiten einfach anders gemacht.
Oder es gibt einfach Creme Brulee Warning, nur noch fünf übrig.
Ja, genau und so. Und dann hast du noch deine Airphone. Auf deinem Telefon kannst du noch bieten und so.
Tauschersteak gegen Bratkartoffeln.
Ja, dass du wirklich so auf die Creme Brulee dann irgendwie bieten kannst.
Die Tische können gegeneinander antreten.
Ich zahle 4,53 Euro, aber ich zahle 4,57 Euro. Die Zeit läuft ab und so.
Viel zu stressig, wenn ich essen gehe, bin ich da nicht so...
Ich sag ja, das wäre für so ein Event. Aber was wäre jetzt für so eine Standard-Restaurantsituation, dass es nie nervt, was wäre eine Information, die ihr gerne auf so einem Display sehen wollen würdet, vorausgesetzt, dass es sich nicht oft updaten darf, damit es nicht zu laut ist?
Wie lange mein Essen noch dauert.
Muss ich... Wie lange deine Bestellung dauert. ZB dass du deine Bestellung überhaupt siehst. Aber dann sieht ja auch jeder andere. Das ist ja auch ein Privacy-Problem.
Außerdem sieht das eh, wenn es auf dem Teller geht. Ich meine, es ist auch nicht so das Drama. Ich meine, du sitzt ja öffentlich da und jeder kann drauf gucken und das Display können ja auch nur Leute sehen, die auch in dem Laden sitzen. Ist jetzt nicht so, dass es im Internet steht.
Wie viele unverheiratete Frauen sind vor Ort? Dafür gibt es andere Lokalitäten wahrscheinlich.
Ein Progressbar für dein Essen.
Ja, oder so Estimated Time of Arrival, so wie bei Flughafen. Du hast halt ein Essensnummer.
Das setzt ja auch voraus, dass du diese Informationen generieren kannst. Also da müsstest du ja in der Küche ablaufen.
Das System ist schon, das wird auf der einen Stelle eingetippt und kommt dann in der Küche auf dem Display.
Ja gut, aber erst wenn es dann komplett fertig ist, gibt es das nächste Update.
Das hilft dir eher nicht, dass du da jetzt ein Progress Bar machst.
Man kann ja schummeln.
Es gibt Cued und irgendwie in Progress und Ding Dong. Es wird ja klassischerweise, du kriegst ja den Zettel da in die Küche ran und irgendwann arbeitet der Koch da seine Cue ab und schnappt sich deinen Zettel und sagt so, ah ja.
Sein Drehding.
Also wenn ich nicht Podcaster geworden wäre, hätte ich sicherlich auch, ich weiß nicht, wer ist denn hier noch alt genug?
Wer ist denn hier noch alt genug?
Wir sind hier alle alt genug.
Super Sendungstitel. Als es noch nicht überall Internet gab. Ich weiß nicht, wer war denn der erste? Also der erste, ich meine dieser Traum von Netz im Restaurant, in der Lokalität, der ist ja auch schon sehr alt. Ich weiß, dass Hans irgendwann mal so ein Projekt da ist, aber irgendwie nichts draus geworden. Und alle haben wir uns eigentlich immer schon so, oder? Also ich zumindest, immer so einen Ort gewünscht, so eine nerd-kompatible Gastronomie, wo man irgendwie am Tisch bezahlen kann.
Und auch bestellen kann.
Ich dachte immer so runde Tische, mit einem Bildschirm in der Mitte, also damals als Bildschirm noch groß war, mit so einer Drehreeling, wo du den Bildschirm sozusagen in jede beliebige Richtung mit einer Tastatur bringen kannst, und dann kannst du da halt irgendwie bestellen. Das würde man natürlich heute alles anders machen, vom eigenen Telefon aus, oder du hast halt irgendwie so ein iPad drin und so. Wie auch immer. Aber immer schon gab es für mich zumindest so diesen Wunsch, so ja, Gastronomie so voll erfahrbar machen. So richtig haben wir das noch nicht. Also zumindest nicht in der Rückmeldung, sondern die haben sich total elektronifiziert, die laufen jetzt alle mit iPads rum, die wissen immer alles. Aber dieses Assuring mit beiden Bestellungen kommt auch wirklich nicht zurück. Und klar, jetzt dieses, wir sagen dir, dass wir diese Bestellung aufgenommen haben und wir haben auch ein oder zwei Checkpoints, wo wir sagen können, das geht voran. Okay, aber ich glaube, das ist jetzt nicht so richtig spannend. Frage ist, was könnte man da noch an Entertainment so mit reinholen?
Beim Österreicher, bei mir um die Ecke, da steht das Austrier übrigens, in der Bergmannstraße kann ich empfehlen, da steht vorne dran an der Tafel, wir haben kein Wi-Fi, ihr müsst euch schon selber unterhalten. Und irgendwie finde ich den Punkt auch ganz gut, weil wenn man die ganze Zeit, ich will gar nicht unbedingt so entertaint werden.
Display und Wi-Fi ist ja nochmal ein Unterschied.
Also wenn da irgendetwas so steht, und sich mal eine Bierliterzahl updatet und vielleicht irgendwelche Bestellnummern und zwischendurch mal irgendwie einen Pong oder irgendwas.
Liter getrunken.
Irgendwas kann da schon passieren, aber jetzt muss man auch nicht die ganze Zeit bespaßeln, weil selten gehe ich alleine in Restaurants, und wenn man dann irgendwie, du kennst das doch, so Bars oder Restaurants, wo so Fernseher und Bildschirme halt hängen, und dann, du kannst gar nicht andern, du guckst dann da halt auch die ganze Zeit hin.
Das liegt daran, dass die sich die ganze Zeit bewegen und die ganze Zeit diesen Sog machen. Aber dieses Flip-Dot-Display ist halt viel cooler, weil es bewegt sich häufig nicht, aber wenn es dann mal ein Update gibt, gibt es auch immer irgendwas von sich.
Es macht immer so krk, krk, krk.
Das heißt, du musst es zurückhaltend machen, aber du hast auch immer den Vorteil, dass wenn was passiert, Leute einen Anlass haben, dahin zu schauen. Ich meine, in gewisser Hinsicht wird es auch so im Allgemeinen Geraune und Geräusche umgehen, untergehen, also wenn es laut ist ohnehin. Aber du wirst dich auch irgendwann dran gewöhnen, dass es da ab und zu mal so ein Update gibt. Ich finde es ein sehr angenehmes Geräusch. Also es ist nicht nervig.
Ja, hast du schon gehört, wenn es die ganze Zeit rattert?
Nein, es soll ja nicht die ganze Zeit, aber wenn es ab und zu mal krk, krk macht, dann ist das ja genauso, als wenn, keine Ahnung, Gläser auf dem Tisch hin und her geschmissen werden. Das findet halt einfach statt.
Ich glaube, die richtige Idee muss halt irgendwie noch gefunden werden. Das ist nicht so easy.
Darf ich mal von einer anderen Idee zwischendurch berichten?
Hat das noch was damit zu tun, mit dem Flip-Dot und so weiter?
Oder wollen wir das Thema dann abschließen?
Mir fällt jetzt erstmal nichts mehr ein, so auf die Schnelle. Außer, dass es halt das Friedelrichter an der Torstraße-Ecke Borsigstraße ist.
Genau, was ich an der Stelle auch nochmal empfehlen möchte, allein schon wegen der netten Leute, die das machen. Und die sind auch extrem, ich meine, das haben wir noch gar nichts dazu gesagt. Das Friedelrichter ist ja jetzt nicht nur, also einerseits ist es ein gutes Restaurant, andererseits haben sie jetzt dieses Display, was schon mal wert ist, angeguckt zu werden. Einfach geiler Nerd-Faktor. Aber sie haben ja auch noch so ein, ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das jetzt beschreiben soll, sie haben ja auch noch verschiedene andere Experimente, das ist jetzt irgendwie so Technology and Food.
Der macht viel mit Pflanzen, mit Nutzpflanzen, die er auch in der Küche dann verwurstelt. Und die growt er da sozusagen im Restaurant selbst, mit auch irgendwie blauem Licht, was da beballert wird. Und jetzt hat er irgendwie Weizen oder Gersten angepflanzt oder so in so Blumenkästen. Also er will da, das ist auf jeden Fall...
Da wächst das Essen noch sozusagen.
So ein bisschen, ja, genau.
Man kann ihm Essen beim Wachsen zugucken.
Und dann hat er auch, er kauft nicht so standardmäßig ein, sondern er hat da irgendwie so einen so in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern irgendwie bekannt oder so, wo er Fleisch und auch sein Grünzeug und Gemüse herholt. Also das wird nicht hier einfach von der Metro oder sonstige gekauft, sondern da geben sie sich schon auch ein bisschen Mühe. Jetzt war gerade eine Fischwoche, da haben sie Zeug irgendwie aus der Ostsee bekommen, so ein paar Kilo Fisch irgendwie ordentlich. Und also die machen nicht so die Standardküche, sondern machen schon auch immer ein bisschen, was gerade so da ist und was Gutes und Frisch und so weiter.
Aber ich würde sagen, lieber abends hingehen.
Man kann es ja sagen, der Huckel war mal da und war mit der Tageskarte nicht zufrieden.
Ich habe die Abendkarte gesehen, die sah geil aus. Die Mittagskarte war halt so relativ unspektakulär. Und weil ich halt in Mitte abends nicht bin, bin ich jetzt noch nicht dazu gekommen, das mal in voller Farbe zu reden.
Also es ist sehr experimental, damit sie am ersten Mal das verstehen, wenn es Sachen gibt, die den Leuten nicht passen.
Also diese rosa Fritten sind geil.
Die gab es auch nicht. Mittags-Kino-Rosa-Fritten? Nee, da gab es wirklich total relativ öde...
Da war ja einfach nur Mittagstag, wie es heißt, das ist ja auch... Ich war bisher immer nur abends da und ich war immer sehr zufrieden. Aber ich bin auch biased, ich kenne ja zumindest 50 Prozent des Teams schon sehr viel länger und weiß, wie gut man da umsorgt wird.
Das stelle ich auch nicht in Frage.
Ich hab da jetzt schon sehr, sehr viel gegessen, natürlich, verständlicherweise. Und das ist alles super.
Deswegen passt du ja nicht mehr hinter den Tisch.
Auch der Nachtisch hier, der hat so einen Apple Pie mit, wo so Gewürze drin sind, die da eigentlich überhaupt gar nicht reingehören. Am Anfang hat er ein bisschen übertrieben, das war die Leute auch teilweise zu scharf. Hat er jetzt ein bisschen runter geregelt, aber es schmeckt halt schon ziemlich, ziemlich cool. Und dann die Polenta, so eine Mais-Polenta, die sahen mich nicht, ich hätte nie gedacht, dass mir das schmeckt. Aber die kam irgendwann mal frisch aus dem Ofen und stand da so und war von oben noch so leicht knusprig irgendwie. Wenn man die so ein paar Stunden länger stehen lässt, dann wird die oben wieder weich, weil sich die Feuchtigkeit wieder oben reinzieht. Aber das war noch so richtig knusprig, so wie so ein Bienenstich oben. Weißt du, so hat das geschmeckt, auch ein bisschen war, glaube ich, auch mit Mandeln und dann seitdem bin ich ja voll Fan von diesen Kuchen. Also der schmeckt wirklich voll super.
Und die Rosa fritten.
Und das frische Brot, sie backen auch ihr Brot da selber. Und dazu dann so Aioli irgendwie mit dem frischen Brot, das ist auch sehr lecker. Also da kann man sich schon durchfressen.
Kann man gut Pfunde ansetzen auf jeden Fall. Friedrich da, Torstraße, Berlin Mitte, unsere Empfehlung mit Flip-Dot-Display. Hand programmiert und verlötet und getestet und in Betrieb genommen von Dennis und Peter.
Ja, genau. Ich hab nämlich jetzt ja auch noch eine tolle Idee zu präsentieren. Zumindest fand ich die ganz witzig. Also ob die jetzt wirklich die Welt revolutionieren würde und alles besser macht, das sei mal dahingestellt. Aber zumindest fand ich es mal, wie man so schön sagt, out of the box gedacht. Und zwar hat sich jemand überlegt, er macht jetzt Videotext für Internet.
Wie für die Webseiten, so Scrolling in der Webseite unten.
Also als mir das jemand gesagt hatte, hab ich erst das nicht so richtig verstanden, weil ich hab zwar mich schon oft gefragt, wie Videotext eigentlich funktioniert hat.
Aus Zastlücke.
Genau, was ich jetzt halt auch mal in der Wikipedia natürlich nachgelesen hab. Und erst, dass ich das dann verstanden hab, hat das andere dann auch Sinn gemacht. Und zwar für die, die jetzt auch nicht wissen, wie Videotext eigentlich funktioniert hat. Genau, das wurde halt irgendwie in so, wie war das, ungenutzten Zeilen vom Signal irgendwie missübertragen?
Folgendermaßen. Der ist, die beim analogen Fernsehen, wird das Bild ja in Zeilen übertragen. Gut, in anderen Formaten auch. Aber dort halt so, dass du hast, also du hast quasi so ein Sägezahnsignal, was dazu führt, dass der einmal der Elektronenstrahl, der das Bild schreibt, von links nach rechts geht und dann wieder zurück und dann wieder von links nach rechts. Und dann gibt es aber den Punkt, wo er unten angekommen ist und dann wieder nach oben muss. So, und das nennt sich Austastlücke. Das Ding ist, dass der braucht ungefähr 20 bis 30 Zeilen, bis er wieder oben ist.
Oder von der Zeit her?
Von der Zeit her. Und damit du das aber nicht als Sägezahn im Ding siehst, auf dem Bildschirm, macht er den Strahl schwarz, sodass er schwarz wieder zurückläuft. Und irgendwann ist man darauf gekommen, dass in dieser Zeit, in der der Strahl braucht, um wieder nach oben zu kommen, dass du da digital Informationen überträgst. Und das war das Videotext.
Genau, und jetzt kommt aber der Knaller eigentlich dabei, weil man sich ja denkt, ja, aber Moment, irgendwie das klingt ja so, als würde das relativ lang dauern. Und wenn man sich noch so erinnern kann an die ersten Fernsehergeräte mit Videotext, dann hat das auch bisweilen sehr lange gedauert. Und wenn der Empfang schlecht war, dann kam halt bestimmten Seiten noch gar nicht. Und später...
Ich glaube, so eine Seite pro Austast-Lücke.
Genau, und was sie dann später in den moderneren Fernsehern gemacht haben, haben sie ja so einen Speicher eingebaut und haben das quasi gebuffert.
Genau.
So, und dann waren halt so... Erst bei den ersten Geräten waren so die bestimmten Hauptseiten, die so bei allen irgendwie gleich bestückt waren so. Und dann gab es ja auch immer so in Deutschland eine einheitliche Struktur, so die waren dann immer da drin. Und später haben die dann halt irgendwie genug Speicher drin gehabt, um das Ganze...
Um die ganze Zeit mitzulesen.
Die ganze Zeit mitzulesen und auch kontinuierlich so ringbuffermäßig zu updaten.
Ja, immer der da reinkam wurde auch übergeschrieben.
So, und jetzt wo man das weiß, weiß man auch, wie das nächste Projekt in etwa gedacht ist. Oder es heißt Lantern oder so. Ich paste mal den Link. Und worum es da geht, ist, dass die Satelliten im Weltall haben, die quasi kontinuierlich essenzielle Teile des Internets quasi per Satellit broadcasten. Da ist irgendein Programm, was da blib macht auf deinem Rechner, Tim. Du hast die Kopfhörer nicht auf, deswegen hast du es nicht gesehen. Genau, nicht gehört. Genau, und zu diesem Satellitensignal bauen sie ein Device, was solarbetrieben ist und Satelliten-Uplink hat und quasi, also Downlinks in dem Fall, und quasi die ganze Zeit, wie beim Videotext, die Fernsehgeräte diesen Ring-Buffer mit eben irgendwie Material füllt. Da sind Wikipedia-Artikel dabei, irgendwie die aktuellen Weltgeschehens-News, Wetterkarten und so weiter. Es ist halt so ein bisschen so dieses Apokalypse kommt, nichts geht mehr und du hast noch ein Device, womit du trotzdem noch irgendwie ein paar Wikipedia, wie mache ich Feuer oder so, lesen kannst. Und die haben halt jetzt gerade, sind sie glaube ich, noch in der Alpha-Phase, da kann man sich sozusagen selber eine Satellitenschüssel nehmen und mit dem Linux irgendwie da schon mal mitspielen und empfangen. Und sie haben eben diese Kickstart oder Indiegogo-Kampagne, um eben diese solarbetriebenen Devices zu bauen, um dann die Free Data from Space Forever quasi kontinuierlich auch empfangen zu können. Das Einzige, was ich daran doof finde oder fand an dem Konzept, war, dass du halt trotzdem noch ein Smartphone oder so brauchst. Also das Ding selber hat dann quasi Wi-Fi oder Bluetooth und dann musst du dich mit deinem Smartphone da draufkonekten, um die Informationen auch zu lesen. Das Ding selber ist wirklich nur ein solarbetriebener Receiver für die Information. Aber ja, also wenn man sich das so durchlegt, wie sie das machen wollen, die schicken da halt so eine Cube-Satz irgendwie ins Weltall. Das ist glaube ich der aktuelle Plan und aktuell sind sie von dem Funding-Goal für 10 Megabyte pro Tag haben sie quasi als Bandbreite, die sie da so rausschippen können.
Also wenn ich das verstanden habe, dann benutzen sie irgendeinen anderen Satelliten und nur wenn sie auf 3 Millimeter kommen, launchen sie ihre eigenen Cube-Sats.
Genau, so war das.
Oder irgendwie so.
Und nochmal, ich muss nochmal kurz zusammenfassen, das heißt sie streamen nicht einfach irgendwas die ganze Zeit raus und ich hab meinen Empfänger da, der dann irgendwie Sachen kriegt, die mich gar nicht interessieren. Oder ich kann sagen, was die für mich raus streamen sollen. Das ist ja pro Person was anderes.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, das ist der gleiche Content für alle.
Aber willst du mal sagen, dass sie am Tag 10 MB von ihrem Satelliten runterschicken?
Na ja, also 10 MB Content ist das, also den sie sozusagen da die ganze Zeit als Ring...
10 MB, der für alle gleich ist. Und nicht nur speziell für mich.
Genau, so groß ist der Ring-Buffer quasi vom Content momentan mit dem aktuellen Funding-Goal. Wenn sie halt da auf eine Mille kommen, dann...
Es ist halt die Frage, wer jetzt entscheidet, was für ein Content da runterkommt. Ich glaube, das eigentliche, was das Internet so interessant macht, ist, dass halt niemand entscheidet, welcher Content ist da jetzt eigentlich drin.
Das Konzept dabei ist ja... Also ich sage ja, wie gesagt, dass das jetzt nicht so die unbedingt global weltverändernde Entwicklung ist, aber ich fand den Gedanken zumindest ganz gut, weil es gibt ja schon die Frage, was passiert denn, wenn jetzt mal Internet an sich so aus ist, oder irgendwie andere größere Probleme oder Abschneidungen von Informationssystemen stattfinden. Wie kommst du jetzt noch an vielleicht essentielle Informationen oder zum Beispiel auch Wikipedia-Artikel? Ist ja schon geil, wenn man so prinzipiell so das, was fürs Leben wichtig ist, immer noch so abrufbar hat.
Ja, aber huckelen, diese 10 MB am Tag oder 20, da passt einmal die Spiegel-Hauptseite und noch eine Unterseite und dann ist es voll.
Also aktuell für das, was wir jetzt gerade haben, sind es halt 350 Wikipedia-Artikel angeblich immerhin.
350? Von wie viel? 100.000?
Ja, Alter!
Alter, das skaliert von vorn bis hinten nicht.
Das ist ja auch nicht dein Internetersatz, versteht das mal. Das geht darum, dass du irgendwie ein Device hast, was Internet unabhängig ist und dir trotzdem noch aktuellen Content liefern kann. Ist halt mal, wie gesagt, so ein bisschen anders gedacht.
Also ich bin total nicht überzeugt.
Also dann will ich aber lieber noch so ein Donkinet haben. So ein Netzwerk, was irgendwie so funktioniert, dass du irgendwie einem Esel einen Sack USB-Sticks aufheizen kannst. Und wo, weiß ich nicht, Requests drin sind, die du halt dann auch nach zwei Wochen, wenn du sie dann erfüllt bekommst, mit dem nächsten Esel noch irgendwie sinnvolles Zeug enthalten.
Das hält ja sinnvolles Zeug. Was halt bei dem Projekt an sich ganz schön ist, ich glaube, ist halt schon ein schönes Bastelprojekt, weil erstens ist es so einigermaßen open source. Zweitens kannst du dir halt die ganze Hardware auch einfach selber stricken und damit zu spielen.
Und drittens ist dieser Prozess, welcher Content da jetzt reinkommt, ist halt jetzt auch sozusagen offen und demokratisch, was nicht unbedingt gut sein muss, geregelt. Und ich finde einfach, das ist so mal ähnlich wie, weiß nicht, ob jetzt, also Bitcoin ist natürlich schon sehr viel bedeutender, aber es ist halt einfach mal so ein Experiment, was ich ganz spannend finde zum Spielen.
Ich bin für solche Experimente immer zu haben.
Ich sage jetzt nicht, dass jeder so eine Lanterne braucht und...
Lanterne.
Lanterne braucht, um jetzt nur noch seinen Content da drüber zu beziehen, aber so zum Spielen und mal gucken, was man eigentlich heutzutage mit der Technologie, die man jetzt für günstig Geld kriegen kann, also machen kann. Und was vielleicht eben an den bestehenden Kommunikationswegen vorbeigeht, vielleicht auf jeden Fall gut. Datenwitz aus den Sternen oder so. Ja, fand ich auf jeden Fall ganz witzig mal oder interessant. Also auch so deren Idee dahinter. Sollte man sich mal durchlesen. Wurde auf jeden Fall auch ganz schön. Ja, das ist, da ist ja das meiste schon gelaufen. Und das Coole ist, jetzt kannst du dir im Prinzip, weil die schon die Alpha-Phase angefangen haben, eben so eine Satellitenschüssel unten im Linux und so ein DVB-S-Empfänger, kannst du jetzt quasi da auch schon mitspielen. Also du musst jetzt auch gar nicht mehr Crowdfunding, um da jetzt schon mal zu gucken, was die da eigentlich so treiben. Jo, das wollte ich mal zumindest gefeatured haben. Als kleines Ding. Was viel wichtiger oder viel toller zum Featuren ist vielleicht noch, es gibt ja hier diese Rails Girls Kampagne und auch in anderen Programmiersprachen und Frameworks wird ja fleißig dafür geworben, dass sich mal Mädels auch mehr wieder mit Technik befassen sollten. Und die Rails Girls waren ja somit die ersten, die da so richtig Wind gemacht haben, wer das mal verfolgt hat. Das ist auf jeden Fall auch eine echt coole Geschichte von eigentlich einem Mädel, was mal angefangen hat programmieren können zu wollen oder sich gedacht hat, ich will mal programmieren lernen, hat sich dann die ganzen Typen geschnappt und hat die ausgefragt, wie das so geht mit dem Programmieren und hat eigentlich alles aufgeschrieben, was sie so dabei gelernt hat und vor allen Dingen, wie sie es gelernt hat und hat dann eben dieses Rails Girls ins Leben gerufen, um das, was sie da so durchgemacht hat, dann den Nachfolgerinnen sozusagen viel einfacher zu machen. Und das ist so von einer kleinen Geschichte zu eigentlich einem weltweiten Phänomen geworden. Wenn man auf Rails Girls Org guckt, dann sieht man, dass mal mittlerweile Workshops auf der ganzen Welt da stattfinden. Und die sind halt auch, soweit ich weiß, immer noch kostenlos für die Teilnehmerinnen und werden halt eigentlich von den Firmen, Start-ups aus der jeweiligen Stadt und Region gesponsert. Und sollte man sich auch mal hier so ein Talk von der Linda, ich vergesse immer den Nachnamen, Ling Ling, warte, ich suche mal grad, wie sie heißt. Die hat auch schon Tab-Talks halten dürfen, dass auch eine mega sympathische junge Frau, die da einiges gerockt hat. Warte mal, ich guck mal gerade, wie die heißt, weil die...
Muss man auch, glaub ich, dazu sagen, wenn ich jetzt nicht gerade irgendwas verdrehe, aber soweit ich weiß, war es ja so, am Anfang waren das Veranstaltungen, die sich ausschließlich oder vor allem an Frauen gewendet haben und mittlerweile geht es eigentlich mehr darum, Parität zu haben. Das heißt, dass man so eine 50-50-Zusammensetzung bekommt.
Das...
Oder hab ich was verdreht? So hab ich es jetzt gerade in Erinnerung. Vielleicht überlagert sich das grad mit was anderem, aber ich hab das auch unter Rails Girls abgespeichert.
Weiß ich jetzt grad nicht genau. Auf jeden Fall heißt die junge Dame Linda Liukas oder so. Ich weiß nicht, wie man das ausspricht. Ich glaub, die ist aus Finnland auch. Auf jeden Fall, da gibt's Ted Talks von der und die hat einfach so viel Karma-Punkte gesammelt, das ist unfassbar mit dieser Aktion, weil die das halt alles gratis gemacht hat. Und das ist übrigens auch so eine generelle Lektion für alle, die denken, ich mach mal Crowdfunding. Das mit dem Crowdfunding, das funktioniert nur, wenn man schon vorher irgendwie Karma-Punkte gesammelt hat. Und die hat so viel Karma-Punkte gesammelt, die wollte dann ein Buch machen, ein Kinderbuch, wie man Programmieren lernt mit Ruby, also mit so handgezeichneten Illustrationen, wirklich kleines Format. Hat die eine Kickstarter-Kampagne gemacht und hat das erste Mal überhaupt nach Geld gefragt und wollte, glaube ich, 30.000 Dollar haben und ja, ich weiß nicht, ich sind auf jeden Fall mehrere 100.000 Dollar geworden, wenn nicht sogar noch mehr. Da kam dann so die ganze, hat sozusagen die ganzen Karma-Punkte an einem Stück mal eingecashed. Also die kann man sich mal hier und da angucken, die ist auf jeden Fall sehr interessant. Und warum ich das jetzt erzähle, ist, weil hier in Berlin ist auch eine ganz starke Fraktion davon und die machen gerade den Rails Girls Summer of Code, wo sozusagen einen ganzen Stapel Geld sammeln, so von Start-ups und auch Einzelpersonen, um eben so ein paar Mädels solche Workshops kostenlos zu ermöglichen. Und da das auch Freunde von mir sehr stark unterstützen und auch gefragt haben, ob ich das mal hier im Podcast erwähnen kann, hier ist der Link im Chat und dann auch in den Show-Notes für den Rails Girls Summer of code.org/campaign, wo sich jeder, der vielleicht von der Firma oder auch privat an diesem hohlen Ziel beteiligen möchte, dann auch beteiligen kann.
Ich sehe gerade, sie hat auch wohl, ich weiß nicht, ob sie es selber alleine gemacht hat, aber steht auf jeden Fall hinter einem Buch, was Hello Ruby heißt.
Das ist dieses Kinderbuch, genau.
Na ja, das hast du gerade erwähnt. Ich habe das gerade überhört, während ich hier nachgeschaut habe.
Und wie viel hat das auf Kickstarter gemacht am Ende?
Ich gucke gerade auf helloruby.com. Das ist so die Homepage von dem ganzen Kram, da steht jetzt zu dem Kickstarter nix.
Ich klicke das mal gerade.
185.000 Dollar.
Ne, 380.000 hat sie mittlerweile. Das habe ich mal meinen Studenten da in der Uni erzählt. Wie, was für ein illustriertes Kinderbuch. 380.000 Jahre mache ich auszufallen, dann muss ich es ihnen auch sagen. Nee, Jungs und Mädels, das geht nicht so. Ihr müsst erst Karma-Punkte sammeln, dann funktioniert das mit dem Crowdfunding. Das kannst du wahrscheinlich mit dem Podcasten genauso bestätigen. Hast ja auch schon ein paar Mal nach einer Spende gefragt, aber auch erst nachdem du schon Podcast rausgeschoben hast, bist du ja...
Absolut, das ist wichtig.
Der Teufel scheißt denn auf den dicksten Haufen, sagt man.
Das verstehe ich jetzt in dem Kontext.
Man muss so eine Menge haben, damit man noch mehr kriegt.
Ich würde das wirklich so mit Karma Punkte sammeln. Und dann irgendwann kann man das auch wieder...
Man muss natürlich schon... Was heißt man muss? Aber es ist sicherlich hilfreich, wenn man vorher in irgendeiner Form klarmacht, wie man es meint. Und dass die Leute sozusagen mit so einem Projektwunsch auch was assoziieren können. Auch über Personen und auch über Dinge, die man schon gemacht hat, ist natürlich immer gut. Das heißt, erstmal ein bisschen was schaffen und Goodwill zeigen und auch zeigen, dass man im Zweifelsfall auch alleine weitermachen würde. Und dann funktioniert das auch gleich sehr viel besser. Das hat mit der Metaebene funktioniert und das hat auch mit Podlove funktioniert. Bist du damit durch? Dann würde ich gleich mal anschließen, wo du das gerade so erwähnst, weil für die Podcaster unter euch, ihr werdet das mehr oder weniger wahrscheinlich eh verfolgen. Aber ich dachte, ich erwähne es jetzt nochmal. Podlove, wir haben von unserem Podlove Publisher gerade wieder eine neue Version rausgebracht. Version 2.1, da sind ein paar nette Features drin. Das ist jetzt erstmal nicht ganz so wichtig, die jetzt hier einzeln aufzuzählen. Wer das interessiert, soll einfach mal auf podlove.org schauen bzw. auf die neue Heimat des Publishers. Da haben wir jetzt noch eine Subdual-Innen aufgemacht unter publisher.podlove.org. D.h. der Publisher selber hat jetzt nochmal seine eigene Webseite bekommen, wo wir das in Zukunft ein bisschen besser dokumentieren wollen, ein bisschen klarer machen wollen, dass das nochmal so ein herausragendes Tool ist. Unabhängig jetzt, also nicht unabhängig, aber so als Teil der Podlove-Initiative, die sich ja für viele Sachen einsetzt. Und der Publisher ist ja so quasi das Hauptprodukt zusammen mit dem Webplayer. Und der Erik, der das macht, der ist ja da auch extrem hinterher. Und der hat ja nun auch in den letzten drei Jahren auch gezeigt, dass er da wirklich viel Energie...
Der war schon mal hier, ne?
Der war auch schon mal hier. Und ist aber jetzt meistens gerade in Malaysia, ist da irgendwie unterwegs und macht eigentlich nichts anderes als das, beziehungsweise will vor allem auch nichts anderes machen. Und wir hatten ja auch das Projekt so ein bisschen mit Crowdfunding gestartet. Gut, da kam einiges rein, das hat ganz gut funktioniert. Aber jetzt müssen wir auch noch mal schauen, ob wir noch mal eine neue Runde starten. Probieren wir jetzt aber auch noch mal ein zweites Modell. Und zwar gibt es halt jetzt hier, was ja auch so in diesem ganzen Plug-In-Bereich für manche Sachen ganz gut funktioniert, zumindest in der WordPress-Welt, dass man sagt, man nutzt hier diese Software regelmäßig und man zahlt für Support regelmäßig. Das heißt, es gibt jetzt hier so ein Support-Modell, wo man eben sagen kann, okay, ich will das hier sowieso regelmäßig unterstützen, kriege aber dann quasi auch einen direkten Support vom Developer. Das heißt, man hat so ein Ticket-System und kann dann halt irgendwie alle möglichen Fragen, Fragen, wenn man Probleme hat oder wenn man irgendwas irgendwie machen will. Also jetzt nicht nur Problemlösungen oder Fehler, sondern halt auch, wie kann man das machen, wie kann man das benutzen, wie kann man mit Templates arbeiten, wie kann man das einrichten etc. Und da gibt es jetzt so ein 3-Säulen-System mit irgendwie 5 Euro, 15 Euro, 55 Euro pro Monat. Also 5 Euro ist natürlich für normalen Podcasts da, der da schon ein Anliegen hat, dass das immer alles gut funktioniert, eine Möglichkeit regelmäßig Support zu geben und eben auch selber Support zu bekommen. Und wenn man halt jetzt professionellen Podcasts macht, dann sind eben die anderen beiden Tarife interessant. Oder wenn man jetzt selber, keine Ahnung, für andere Kunden Podcasts aufsetzt oder betreibt, Webseiten betreibt und da immer wieder ein Problem reinläuft, dann kann man halt hier Support kriegen bis hin zu Erik Loxig halt in dieses Thema ein und schaut selber mal, was da irgendwie schiefläuft mit der Webserver-Konfiguration, PHP dreht durch etc. Es kommt ja dann doch mal wieder so Sachen hoch, um die man sich vielleicht nicht selber kümmern möchte. Dann kann man das so machen. Das ist auch ein Modell. Aber damit ist das Thema schon durch. Aber wir bleiben mal gleich bei dem Bereich Veranstaltung. Und zwar auch zu Gast bei uns war vor einiger Zeit der Markus Schubert, doch Schub, der uns ja so einiges Lustiges erzählt hat mit seinen Geospielchen und so weiter. Und unter anderem hat er auch berichtet von dieser Theaterproduktion Spiel des Lebens. Ich weiß nicht, hat das einer von euch mal gesehen eigentlich?
Gesehen hab ich es nicht, nee, aber blumig umschrieben bekommen.
Genau, wir haben das hier auch blumig umschrieben und ihr habt es alle blumig umschrieben bekommen. Und jetzt ist es wohl so, dass dieses Spiel des Lebens, was kurz gesagt so das Spiel des Lebens, dieses Brettspiel übersetzt in so eine reale, theaterartige Erlebniswelt, dass das jetzt wieder neu aufgesetzt wird. Und da gibt es jetzt so verschiedene Termine, wo das stattfindet. In Berlin im Ballhaus Ost. Das geht am 16. Mai mit einer Premiere los und dann gibt es irgendwie eine ganze Latte von Terminen durch den Mai hindurch bis zum 30. Mai, wenn ich das jetzt hier richtig überblicke. Und da kann halt Leute Tickets erwerben und Spaß haben. Und weil wir euch alle so lieb haben und weil ihr so tolle Hörer seid, wer Interesse hat, da bei zu sein am der Premiere, am 16. Mai um 19 Uhr Zeit hätte. Was ist das für ein Tag? 16. Mai, ich schau mal kurz, ist ein Samstag. Samstag, der 16. Mai. Wer da am 19 Uhr Zeit hätte und Lust hätte, dabei zu sein, der soll uns doch einfach mal über Twitter anhauen. Die ersten beiden, die sich melden bei uns, die kriegen ein Ticket für die Premiere. Ja, das ist das. Und dann hab ich noch was, und zwar gibt's hier wieder in Berlin. Das ist mal alles in Berlin, ich weiß. Aber wir kennen ja nichts anderes. Wir kennen nichts anderes. Und wir wissen auch nicht, was woanders passiert. Ihr könnt das aber auch mal erzählen, oder? Bei Logbook Netzpolitik hatten wir mal Termine, da kamen dann Termine, da kamen Leute mit Ankündigungen.
Ja, aber wenn wir es nicht...
Nee, wir sagen jetzt nichts anderes, aber wir lassen uns auch schon mal auf irgendwas hin stupsen oder so.
Wenn's cool ist, ja.
Genau, weil wenn es uns nicht interessiert, dann sagen wir pff.
Ja, aber stupsen lassen wir uns doch sowieso.
Stupsen lassen wir uns schon. Vielleicht ist es auch geil nochmal.
Sagen wir, in alter Berliner Tradition, ja, da kann man nicht meckern.
Das hat man aber gesechselt, Alter.
Oder wie der Engländer sagt, not bad.
Not too shabby.
Genau, not too shabby. Not too shabby ist auch eine Veranstaltung hier am 14. Mai. Ist alles bald. 14. Mai in der Kalkscheune, auch in Berlin, als Open Tech Summit. Und ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich das ausreichend beschreiben kann, aber das ist so ein ganzer Tag, wo es so um Open Hardware geht, unter anderem so bau deine eigene Fernbedienung, Strickmaschine, Ampelschaltung, was auch immer, Encyclopedien. Also es ist so ein bisschen so eine Sammel-Community-Event für Leute, die so Wikipedia, Freifunk, selber-Mach-Netzwerke, selber-Mach-Hardware, etc. gut finden und die dort quasi sich mit offener Technologie auseinandersetzen wollen da zusammenkommen. Das ist also so ein Community-Event, der sich vor allem an Open Source-Communities wendet und Basel-Communities wendet und das findet am, hab ich schon gesagt, 14. Mai statt, genau, Donnerstag. Gibt's auch noch Tickets. Link ist in den Show-Notes.
Show-Notes.
Genau. Das war der Veranstaltungsteil der Freak Show.
Noch eine kleine Mini-Plug-ung eines Kollegen, muss ich noch vornehmen.
Mini-Plug-ung eines Kollegen.
Und zwar ein sehr netter Kollege von mir, der Arash aus Iran kommt, lebt da aber schon sehr lange nicht mehr, aber ist trotzdem ein ganz netter Zeitgenosse, der auch so Frontend-Programmierer bei VUGA ist und der lernt gerade Deutsch, und ich muss ja mal sagen, also bei VUGA lernen viele Leute Deutsch, und ich hatte lange Zeit gesagt, lasst es einfach, weil in Berlin geht das auch ohne, aber es gibt anscheinend einige richtig gute Kurse, wo verschiedenste Kollegen aus unterschiedlichsten Ländern und Regionen dieser Erde in drei Monaten verdammt gut Deutsch gelernt haben. Also wirklich zu einem Punkt, wo ich so meinte, du sprichst aber gut, und er meinte so, ja, ne, also ich kann mich mit dem Finanzamt unterhalten, aber ansonsten, ich meinte so, ne, ne, ne, wenn du dich mit dem Finanzamt unterhalten kannst, dann bist du angekommen, so, das ist... Dann Respekt, so, dann brauchst du nie, da fehlt nicht mehr viel, ja.
Das können ja selbst Muttersprache sein, unbedingt.
Und auf jeden Fall der kleine, die kleine Promo für jetzt diesen Kollegen ist, der lernt Deutsch und er hatte irgendwie ein Problem, jetzt Vokabular zu lernen und er meinte irgendwie, ja, das Vokabular, was man sonst zu lernen, das kann man halt im Alltag nicht so gebrauchen. Er meinte, er hatte so das Bedürfnis, wenn er eine Mail kriegt, zum Beispiel von der Bank oder so, ja, und er versteht die nicht, dass er diese Mail einfach direkt so in einen Vokabeltrainer reinpipet und sozusagen nach Häufigkeit der benutzten Worte und so weiter und so fort das sortiert und dann kriegt er das sozusagen dann dieser bekannten Vokabellernschleife einfach auch so reingepfräst. Das heißt, die nächste Mail, die er von der Bank dann kriegt, dann versteht er auch einfach so die Wörter sozusagen schon direkt viel besser. Und diese App heißt LaFro. Der Mann hat einen Afro, ich vermute, das ist eine Anspielung da drauf. Ich suche den mal gerade im App Store.
Apostroph LaFro.
Ne, ich verlink das mal gerade. Und alles, was ihr dafür tun oder was ihr jetzt aufgerufen seid zu tun, ist die mal runterzuladen, das glaube ich auch kostenlos. Und er will einfach ein bisschen Feedback und Input, weil bisher haben das wohl nur 33 Leute gefunden von sich aus und alleine. Und da gab es jetzt noch nicht so viel zu holen. Und er ist da irgendwie gerade fleißig am Schrauben und will einfach mal das Leute das ausprobieren und ihm sagen, was sie davon halten, ist wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht die geilste Ab, die ihr jemals gesehen habt. Aber der ist nett und ich habe ihm gesagt, pass auf, ich sag das mal den Freak Show-Hörern, die sind da ganz aktiv und...
Also liebe Freak Show-Hörer, geht das auch mit anderen Sprachen?
Ich kenne viele Leute, die hören Podcasts, um Deutsch zu lernen.
Genau, noch kurz die Frage von Dennis. Ich glaube, es geht für alle Sprachkombinationen.
Also es können auch Leute benutzen, die halt Englisch, Spanisch, Italienisch, sonst irgendwas lernen wollen.
Genau, er benutzt halt da, weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob er jetzt wirklich nur Google Translator benutzt, aber er benutzt halt da irgendeine Art hier auch, also er sortiert die Wörter dann, die du da reinschiebst, oder die Texte und sortiert die in der Häufigkeit und translated die und er meinte zu mir, glaube ich, dass es auch mit allen möglichen Kombinationen ginge. Wobei sein Fokus jetzt auf Deutsch.
Aber was ich nicht verstehe ist, warum empfiehlst du denn, wieso sagst du denn den Leuten, sie brauchen kein Deutsch zu lernen?
Nein, nein, nein, ich hab denen das nicht gesagt. Ich hab nur so, also als sie mich so gefragt haben, ja, was meinst du, muss ich jetzt hier Deutsch lernen? Ich meine, ja, müssen, lohnt es sich, ja, wie lange willst du denn bleiben? Also das ist jetzt so eine Frage, dass die, also, letztendlich ist natürlich alles viel einfacher, wenn man das lernt, klar.
Also erstens, ich finde, es lohnt sich immer, eine andere Sprache zu lernen. Das ist bei natürlichen Sprachen nicht anders als bei programmierten Sprachen. Gerade Deutsch.
Das war ganz kurz nur so als Kontext. Ich meine, die arbeiten halt in einer Firma, wo die Geschäfts-, also wo Englisch gesprochen wird, tagtäglich, ne? Die sind in einer Social Bubble, sozusagen auch mit ihren Kollegen drin. Gerade, wenn die von weiter herkommen und jetzt hier nicht sofort eine eigene Social Bubble sich ergründen, ne? Dann sind die sowieso in so einer Feedback Loop drin, wo auch privat die ganze Zeit Englisch gesprochen wird. Und sobald die in irgendeinen Laden gehen und auf Deutsch anfangen, so was versuchen zu sagen, wird hier überall sofort auf Englisch geswitcht. Also es ist auch, sagen wir mal, als Motivation total schwierig, den Bedarf zu erkennen, weil du es gar nicht musst in den allermeisten Situationen. Das ist in Berlin auch schon, alle Kollegen, die ich dazu mal befragt hab, die meinten so, es ist echt schwer, sich jetzt drei Monate irgendwie in die Sprache zu gehen, wenn du merkst, dass eigentlich eh alle mit ihr Englisch hier sprechen.
Gab's auch mal so ein Comic von Maha, oder? Mit diesen vier europäischen Ländern, wo die versuchen halt die Sprache des Landes zu sprechen. Die Franzosen so gleich, ach hier, geh weg, du sollst nicht Französisch sprechen. Die Deutschen antworten, egal wie gut der Deutsch kann, antworten immer in Englisch. Die Italiener so, wow, guck mal, er spricht Italienisch, machen sie es so, finden das voll toll. Und ich glaube irgendein anderes Land, die Engländer oder so, die weiß nicht, was da war, aber es war, ich glaube, es passte ganz gut.
Ich glaube, wenn du irgendwie, sagen wir, du würdest jetzt irgendwo mitten auf dem Land jetzt ein Jahr in Deutschland verbringen, klar, dann macht das absolut perfekt Sinn und dann ist das auch lebensnotwendig wahrscheinlich. Aber in Berlin ist halt schwierig. Nichtsdestotrotz, jetzt wo ich gesehen hab, wie schnell man das lernen kann, weil ich persönlich denke mir immer so, mit den ganzen Artikeln, mit diesen ganzen Ausnahmeregeln, wie erklärst du, wie man das CH-CH-CH-KH klingen kann und es gibt keine normale Regel, die dir das zum Beispiel sagt oder die S-laute. Es gibt halt unendliche Ausnahmen dieser Sprache. Das ist zumindest nicht richtig.
Also Deutsch ist eine der logischsten und der schließbarsten Sprachen überhaupt. Wenn du eine Sprache mit Ausnahmen ohne Ende haben willst, dann ist das Englisch und Französisch. Also Englisch und Französisch sind die Sprachen, wo Schrift und gesprochene Sprache nichts miteinander zu tun haben.
Aber du weißt nicht, ob es der, die oder das Butter ist. Es gibt keine Regel dafür.
Aber das ist aber egal. Du kannst auch irgendwie die Butter sagen.
Es gibt keine Regel, wo du weißt, ob es CH-CH oder KH ist. Gibt's nicht? Doch, doch, doch. Es gibt ein paar, aber es gibt sehr viele Ausnahmen davon.
Ja, bei Englisch ist das viel schlimmer.
Nein, Englisch ist viel schlimmer. Ich meine, da hast du dieselbe Schreibung und fünf verschiedene Ausnahmen.
Du musst die Entymologie eines Wortes bis ins Mittelalter kennen.
Das Problem ist, bei Englisch hast du eine ganz andere Umgebung. Du hörst und siehst und...
Also, was du eigentlich sagen willst, Englisch kann man halt.
Nein, nein, nein.
Das lese ich überhaupt nicht ein. Wenn du in Deutschland bist, hast du auch die Umgebung. Ein Vorteil von Deutschland ist, hier sprechen echt eine Menge Leute Deutsch.
Die meistgesprochene Sprache in Europa.
Ja, ja, eben. A ist es erstmal keine unwichtige Sprache, weil sehr viele Leute sprechen das. Und wir wissen alle, wie groß der Unterschied ist zwischen Native Speaking und irgendwie broken English.
Diese ganzen Argumente, die du jetzt bringen musst, die sind mir alle total klar. Trotzdem, ich unterhalte mich mit diesen Leuten auf täglicher Basis und ihrer Erfahrung. Und ich kann dir sagen, diese ganzen Ausnahmeregelungen im Deutschen sind für die schon auch echt hart. Und gerade diese Artikel und gerade die ganzen Sachen, wo es eigentlich eine Regel gibt. Und dann aber in den entscheidenden Momenten gibt es eben doch die Ausnahmen. Zum Beispiel das Werben der Bewegung. Da sagt man halt, ich bin gegangen, wo alle anderen werben, eine andere und so weiter.
Aber in all ihren Muttersprachen ist es genauso. Da hast du auch solche Ausnahmen. Und wir können einfach Leute, die danach sich irgendwie an ihr Unix-Terminal setzen und dann irgendwie für jedes einzelne Kommando, die Minus V, Minus Minus V oder irgendwie ohne Minus die Option schreiben, die wollen mir dann irgendwie erzählen, sie werden nicht in der Lage, mit Ausnahmen umzugehen. Also don't, just don't. Der Punkt ist, klar sagt man das. Aber du hast auch selber vorhin schon gesagt, wie gut kann man, wenn man es will, und das hat auch ein bisschen was mit der Außenmotivation, die man zugesteckt bekommt, zu tun, man kann sehr gut Deutsch lernen. Man kann jede Sprache sehr gut lernen, wenn man es intensiv und motiviert macht.
Ja und mit dem richtigen Input auch natürlich, weil zum Beispiel gibt es halt viele Kollegen, die haben so am Goethe-Institut diesen...
Übrigens hast du dieses Artikel-Ding, hast du übrigens auch im Englischen, du hast es zwar nicht im Zö, aber wenn du, was weiß ich, eine Ziege, ist das Hi, Schie oder It? Ja, da hast du nämlich genau dasselbe Ding. Ja, du hast das in diesen Sprachen auch, du hast das bloß nicht im Artikel. Also es ist nicht so, dass es das auch in anderen Sprachen gäbe. Und Deutsch ist halt in vielerlei Hinsicht sehr viel einfacher zu erlernen, allein schon, weil du eben von der Schreibung auf die Sprache schließen kannst. Du siehst das Wort, wie es geschrieben ist und du bist 99% an der Aussprache. Im Englischen ist die Aussprache, wie es geschrieben ist, ein Scheiß. Also das sagt nichts aus. Das ist nichts aus als ein Hash Value in irgendeiner Aussprache.
Das ist aber wirklich so. Eine Weile lang, da hab ich halt viel Englisch gelesen.
Larf und tough und baum.
Aber wenig gehört und gesprochen. Und dann kommst du halt auf so ein Wort, du liest es in so einem Text. Ja, du kannst es auch nachgucken, was es bedeutet. Aber wie spricht man es aus? Also so zum Beispiel Larf und tough und baum.
Achso, auf Deutsch meinst du jetzt?
Sense auf Deutsch, auf Englisch. Da dachte ich total lange, das würde Skivvy ausgesprochen wird, aber Skyth ausgesprochen. S-K-Y-T-H-E.
Aber einen Argument würde ich jetzt mal kurz nach anführen. Ist ja alles ganz gut und schön, was ihr erzählt, aber es ist echt lange her, dass ihr Deutsch gelernt habt. Und wahrscheinlich auch das Umfeld, in dem ihr Deutsch gelernt habt, ist ganz anders, als wenn ihr gerade aus Iran kommen würdet, um Deutsch zu lernen. Also ich möchte das mal kurz trotzdem noch relativierend anführen, dass Englisch halt einfach weltdurchdringend ist und du das in allen Ecken und Enden in Fernsehsendungen, Musik und TV, halt um die Ohren geballert kriegst und dadurch schon eine ganz andere... Und es hat einen anderen Nutzwert, weil du kannst halt, wenn du Englisch kannst, kannst du einfach in jedem Land der Erde mehr oder weniger sinnvolle Dinge tun, weil es halt so die Lingua Franca mit ist.
Na ja, also ich weiß nicht, in Novosibirsk war das eher schwierig.
Also erstens gibt es genug Regionen, wo das nicht der Fall ist.
Ja, aber es ist viel mehr als Deutsch.
Gar keine Frage, aber es handelt sich dabei nicht um Englisch, sondern um Broken Englisch.
Egal, wenn du aus Iran kommst, dann ist die Wahl jetzt...
Niemand stellt in Abrede, dass das Englisch Premier Gloo ist. Aber ich will an dieser Stelle auf einen Podcast verweisen, den ich gemacht habe im Rahmen meines Forschergeist-Podcasts. Ich schmeiße das gleich mal hier in den Chat. Sehr interessant. Und zwar habe ich mich mit Peter Eisenberg unterhalten. Der ist der Typ, der unter anderem eine der Hauptwerke, der deutschen Grammatik niedergeschrieben hat. Er ist sozusagen ein anerkannter Sprachwissenschaftler. Sehr interessanter Podcast. Nicht nur, weil es viel um was Deutsch als Sprache ausmacht. Also insbesondere als Wissenschaftssprache. Im Sinne von was kann man in Deutsch denken, was man in einer anderen Sprache nicht denken oder ausdrücken kann. In der Hinsicht. Und auch so seine ganze Geschichte ist sehr interessant, weil er halt so in frühen Zeiten beim MIT gewesen ist, als das losging so mit Noam Chomsky und Joseph Weizenbaum, als Eliza entwickelt wurde. Also auch eine sehr, sehr interessante persönliche Geschichte. Und dieses ganze Verhältnis zwischen Sprache, Denken und auch so Linguistik im Computersinne da einfach wunderbar zur Sprache kommt. Und da fängt man auch ein bisschen anders an, über das Deutsche nachzudenken.
Ich wollte ja auch, wie gesagt, die Einleitung der Geschichte war ja, dass ich am Anfang, als diese Frage kam, dachte, naja, weiß nicht wie lange so was dauert. Und jetzt, wo ich halt gemerkt habe, dass man das auch in drei Monaten relativ gut hinkriegt, machen das ja auch alle möglichen Leute. Und die, die immer so drei Monate mit dem Finanzamt reden können, das war, glaube ich, tatsächlich vom Goethe-Institut. Und, ja, also kann man schon mal machen. Ist auch echt ganz witzig, weil ich hatte, wir machen auch immer so Dienstags, machen wir so slow German-Lunch. So hat das angefangen, dass ich irgendwie mit so ein paar Leuten Mittagessen gehe. Und das war dann halt irgendwann geil. Da saß dann an einem Tisch eine Däne in Argentinien, ein Kolumbianer, ein Iraner und ein Serbe und ich. Und wir haben alle Deutsch gesprochen, das war total bizarr. Und dann sprechen halt auch der Argentinier und der Kolumbianer miteinander Deutsch. Ein slow German. Ja, das ist mittlerweile gar nicht so slow mehr.
Und hören die dann auch langsam gesprochene Nachrichten von der deutschen Welle?
Ein paar von denen haben das auch gemacht, ja.
Und? Das muss ganz geil sein, wenn man kein Deutsch kann, wenn man Deutsch kann. Das macht das einen wahnsinnig. Habt ihr das schon mal gehört?
Nee, ich hab da mal reingehört, ja, aber...
Also, das schmerzt so ein bisschen, wenn man selber so eine Sprache so gut kann. Und dann ist irgendwie, da hat man einfach so ein Flow. Können wir hier mal kurz mal reinhören?
DW, Deutsch lernen mit Nachrichten. Mittwoch, 29. April 2015, 9 Uhr in Deutschland. Nigeria's Armee befreit 300 Frauen und Mädchen aus Boko Haram Lagern. In Nigeria hat die Armee nach eigenen Angaben 200 Mädchen.
Wie Bundeskanzlerin Angela Merkel bei einer Pressekonferenz verlautbaren ließ, sind die Deutschen meistens nicht ausreichend in der Lage, einer langsam gesprochenen Nachricht zu folgen.
Freak Show heute in Langsam.
Langsam gesprochene Freak Show. Ja, das wäre, das wäre mal was. Aber das geht ja auf den Podcast, kann man ja einfach langsamer machen. Podcasts sind einfach so universell.
Wahrscheinlich kann man den aber richtig gut beschleunigen. Vielleicht noch viel besser als unser Genuschel.
Ich hab an den Podcast ja fünffache Geschwindigkeit.
Ja, aber wir nuscheln ja auch beim Schnellsprechen und der nicht. Das heißt, den kann man ja am Ende sogar schneller als wir.
Ja, man könnte sagen, es sind vor allem deutlich gesprochene Nachrichten. Aber ich hab sowas gesucht, in Spanisch gibt's bestimmt, ich hab's bloß nicht gefunden. Weil du hast natürlich das Problem, wenn du in so Original-Content reingehst, die reden dann einfach so dermaßen schnell.
Ja, oder sie lachen die ganze Zeit.
Gut, dass wir das nicht machen. Deutsche sind ja so humorlos, da kann man wenigstens auch verstehen, worüber geredet wird.
Ich hab übrigens noch eine total tolle Entschleunigung vorgenommen, falls ihr noch mehr hören wollt von nicht computerbezogenen Themen.
Ich hab ja auch noch ein großes Thema eigentlich, was ich mit euch besprechen wollte. Bevor wir vollkommen durch sind, würde ich das gerne noch mal…
Na dann, hau rein.
Es sei denn, du hast was ganz, ganz kurzes.
Ja, weiß ich nicht, mach mal. Aber auch nicht so lange.
Ja, ich möchte über Slack reden. Weil Slack ist, glaub ich, gerade heißer Scheiß und ist ja meines Wissens noch nicht zur Sprache gekommen.
Doch.
Irgendwann haben wir das schon mal erwähnt.
Bei der Sendung, wo du nicht dabei warst.
Die es nicht gibt.
Wann haben wir das erwähnt?
Ja, es ist so Chat, aber ich finde es einfach, also erstmal was ist das? Also Slack ist ein Kommunikationssystem.
Chatgruppen-Chatsystem.
Genau, für Workgroups sozusagen.
Sagen wir mal Irk mit History.
Irk mit Funktionierend.
Ja, mit, also.
Und ohne Spam.
Ich würde das jetzt nicht auf Irk Münzen. Es ist halt ein Chat, der irgendwie ordentlich funktioniert und der vor allem mit korrekten Apps daherkommt. Also es gibt eine ordentliche iOS-App, es gibt eine ordentliche Mac-App, was für mich sehr wichtig ist. Also ich finde, alle Systeme haben immer so Browser.
Das sind aber auch alles nur Webviews.
Ja, aber sie sind gut. Es ist gut gemacht, also du merkst...
Sind dafür, dass es Webviews sind, sind es ziemlich gut.
Dafür, dass es Webviews sind, ist es wirklich ziemlich gut. Da habe ich auch schon Gegenteiliges gesehen. Und ich finde diese Slack extrem pfiffig. Der Laden wird ja mittlerweile enorm gehyped. Die haben ja da irgendwie fette Investoren und steigen im Wert irgendwie minütlich an. Ich schätze mal, die werden alle reich. Fragt man sich natürlich, warum eigentlich? Also man kann bei Slack, wer jetzt Slack noch nicht kennt, also wenn man jetzt so eine Workgroup hat und wir benutzen das jetzt zum Beispiel für PodLav und wir hatten vorher so eine Melange mit Skype und dann haben wir ja noch Trello und dann haben wir noch GitHub-Issues und Pipapo, dann haben wir noch Blog und den Twitter-Account, wie das eben so ist. Man hat so diese ganze Wolke und ist die ganze Zeit beschäftigt, die Information aus dem einen System in das nächste System zu übertragen, um dann darüber reden zu können, um davon Kenntnis zu halten. Hast du mein Update auf die Karte im Trello gesehen und hier ist ein neues GitHub-Issue und bla bla bla. Diese ganzen Sachen, ich hab was getwittert, ich hab was geblockt. Die ganze Zeit ist man damit beschäftigt, diese Informationen immer wieder in die Kommunikation reinzutragen und viele Kanäle zu haben. Irgendwann hatten wir dann so 10, 20 Skype-Chats und trotzdem war alles extrem mühsam. Neulich kann noch einer sagen...
Ja, vor allen Dingen, weil Skype auch so merkwürdig ist mit History bewahren und dann kommt jemand online und dann ist plötzlich ganz viel History da, weil der hat dann in irgendeiner Gruppe was gesagt, aber man selber war nicht online und dann waren lange Zeit die Leute, die in dieser Konversation anwesend waren nicht online und dann kommt einer online, plötzlich hast du 200 Messages gewesen, eine History plötzlich in diesen Dings drin und so.
Aber selber schuld, warum bist du auch nicht online?
Ja, mein Tag ist irgendwann zu Ende, weißt du so.
Genau, das ist so ein Aspekt und Slack bringt das irgendwie gut zusammen, weil du hast halt Direct Messages, du hast Channels, also quasi offene Chats, man kann jederzeit welche machen und man hat das in so einem Single-Window-Interface alles mit drin.
Man merkt dich relativ gut, was du schon gelesen hast. Auch über verschiedene Geräte und so weiter?
Genau, das funktioniert alles sehr ordentlich. Man kann einzelne Chatbeiträge pinnen und favoriten und pipapo. Also überhaupt ist viel so, wie man es sich denkt.
Dass es einfach sein müsste?
Genau, wie es einfach so sein müsste. Sowohl was man aus seiner eigenen Chat-Historie herkennt, als auch was der Bedarf ist und es liegt daher. Vor allem funktioniert es gut, es performt.
Es ist jetzt nicht das herausragende Feature, das nur Slack hat, sondern es ist einfach alles, wie es sein muss.
Genau, nichts zackt richtig. Dann kommen noch ein paar gute Sachen hinzu, die ich sehr wichtig finde, nämlich dieses Problem dieser Vernetzung verschiedener Subsysteme, die man auch noch braucht. Es gibt die sogenannten Integrations. Und eine Integration ist dann immer so eine Anbindung an ein anderes System, also zum Beispiel Twitter oder wahrscheinlich auch Facebook, das benutze ich nicht, aber wir haben ja irgendwie GitHub drin. Ich muss gerade mal gucken, was wir alles benutzen.
Es gibt irgendwie 60, 70 Integrations, also da kann man lange klicken, um zu gucken, was da alles gibt. Die nachfolgenden Sendungen verschieben sich um.
Ja, also es gibt richtig viele, ich sag mal erst mal nur, welche wir jetzt gerade benutzen, weil wir benutzen das auch kostenlos, das wollen wir noch dazusagen und kostenlos hat man Limits. Man hat erstens keine ewige Historie, also man hat nur irgendwie 10.000 Messages und dann fallen die irgendwie raus. Also wenn man quasi ein ewiges Archiv der Kommunikation haben will, dann müsste man im Prinzip schon zahlen. Zum Zahlen komme ich gleich nochmal. Und man hat eben auch nur maximal sechs Integrations, wobei sechs Integration nicht sechs einzelne Quellen sind, sondern sechs verschiedene Arten, also Subsysteme quasi, die man anbindet, von denen man dann mehrere Quellen haben kann. Also zum Beispiel GitHub kann man sich halt Issues, Commits und diesen ganzen Kram in den Chat mit reinwerfen lassen. Das heißt, ich kann sagen, hier, ich verbinde mich mit GitHub und dann sage ich, wenn ein neues Issue für dieses Repo auftaucht, dann poste das bitte in diesem Channel. Oder wenn es hier ein Commit gibt, dann poste das in diesem Channel. Und dann kriegt man halt immer so ein Update, dann kommt quasi der Bot und sagt, hier, es hat einen Commit gegeben, gebt damit gleich noch ein bisschen Kontext und alle Links mit dazu. Das heißt, es taucht einfach so im Chat auf, man klickt da drauf bzw. man muss noch nicht mal draufklicken, sondern man sieht schon eigentlich aus dem Beitrag so, ah, okay, der und der hat das und das gesagt, interessiert mich jetzt oder interessiert mich jetzt nicht. Wir benutzen GitHub, wir benutzen RSS, also alle möglichen Feeds quasi, was weiß ich, von irgendwelchen Systemen. In unserem Fall ist das die Podlauf-Community, also das Discourse-System, was hier als solches noch nicht unterstützt wird. Travis CI, dieses permanente...
Continuous Integration.
Continuous Integration. Dann natürlich Trello, was für uns sehr wichtig ist für die Planung, Twitter, Updates, GitHub wie erwähnt und Code Climate. Das ist so, das macht so Code Review. Das guckt immer durch deinen Code durch und gibt dir so Tipps, was da so scheiße ist. Und naja, dann gibt es auch noch tonnenweise andere Integrations, die man jetzt auch noch rein machen könnte. Hier, was weiß ich, hier, die ganzen anderen Source Code Systeme, Bitbucket und Box und Dropbox.
Wir haben ja irgendwie so eine Integration, wo der Build-Server dann auch immer den Status in Eingangsbestand sondern Channel-Einfos.
Und Hangouts und hast du nicht gesehen und Heroku und EFTTT und so. Also da kann man wahrscheinlich...
Das klingt so ein bisschen, wenn man immer diese ganzen Social Networks und was auch immer miteinander kombiniert. Kennen ihr diesen einen Prank, ich weiß nicht mehr, wer das war, der zwei Chinese Restaurants miteinander verbunden hat. Erstmal den einen anruft und sagt, jetzt kommt gerade noch ein Freund rein, der will auch noch was bestellen und dann redet er ein bisschen an und dann hält er die beiden Hörer aneinander und dann quatschen so eine halbe Stunde lang die beiden Chinese Restaurants und versuchen, um herauszufinden. Das kommt mir immer auch so vor. Vor allen Dingen, wenn du if, wie heißt das, if this, then that, wenn du das mit reinbringst, da hast du ja im Prinzip auch schon so einen Meta-Sammelservice.
Ja, ich überlege gerade, ob ich vielleicht mal eine RSS-Integration zwischen der EFTTT-Integration mache, weil dann kann ich da flexibler Feeds vorbereiten. Das ist gleich mal die Idee. Hier so Pivotal Tracker, Subversion, The Whole Enchilada, und sie fügen auch am laufenden Meta neue Sachen hinzu. Und das macht das alles sehr attraktiv und man will dann eigentlich irgendwann, überlegt man sich so, oh das ist aber total wertvoll, jetzt wäre ich ja auch bereit dafür was zu bezahlen und dann sieht man die Preise. Und die Preise, naja, also...
Das sind eher so Business to Business Preise, ne?
Ja, das Ding ist, du zahlst erst mal... Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob man überhaupt einen globalen Account haben kann, dass man so einen Account über mehrere Communities hinweg hat. Ich glaube man hat in jeder Community einen eigenen Account, ne?
In jedem Team, ja.
In jedem Team hat man so einen eigenen Account und man kann dann aber mit mehreren eingeloggt sein und die abmacht. Bist du mit mehr als einem? Wie viel?
Momentan zwei.
Und du hast in jedem ein anderes Passwort und im Prinzip einen ganz anderen Account, ein ganz anderes Profil und alles ist anders?
Ja, das Ding ist, dass das momentan gerade migriert wird bei uns von einer normalen Lösung zu irgendeiner In-House-Lösung und keine Ahnung, die sind da am Machen und am Tun, deswegen hab ich da zwei. Als ich bei dieser Konferenz in England war, da hatten die für diese Konferenz auch noch mal einen Slack aufgesetzt, da hatte ich das da irgendwie auch noch drin. Das ist alles irgendwie ein bisschen unschränkend mit diesen ganzen Teams, aber...
Ich sag mal, in der Regel ist man nicht in so vielen Teams, wo man wirklich arbeitet. Also klar, man hat jetzt vielleicht in der Company eins oder...
Nee, wenn man in vielen Teams ist, dann arbeitet man ja auch nicht mehr, dann sitzt man in vielen Teams.
Das kommt noch dazu. Aber in unserem Fall, wir sind halt Open Source Projekt und das ist halt unabhängig, sagen wir mal, von so einem Arbeitskontext für die meisten.
Ich hab auch für den Minecraft-Server einen Minecraft-Slack und in der Firma gibt es auch noch einen.
Ah, kannst du mich da mal einladen?
Zu dem Minecraft-Slack? Klar, wieso das denn? Wieso nicht? Wir sind mal gucken, was wir über Minecraft quatschen, aber ihr wollt Slack jetzt machen.
Erstens brauche ich mal ein zweites Slack-Team, wo ich dabei bin, um das mal so zu experiencien und zweitens würde mich das mal interessieren, ob mich das anfigst.
Haha, Minecraft. Nee, ich glaube, spielen macht mehr Spaß als da lesen. Da werden nur so Sachen koordiniert. Wäre jetzt für welches Bauprojekt noch irgendwie Bock hat mitzubuddeln und Updates, wäre jetzt was schon als neue Farmen eingebaut hat und so.
Ist jetzt nicht so, da ist nicht so viel los. Wenn du so zwei Teams hast, dann bekommst du halt hier da ganz links noch ein zweites Icon und dann kannst du da drauf tippen.
War da halt kein zweites Fenster?
Dann hast du halt hier zwei Teams, das ist irgendwie zwei Fenster. Keine Ahnung, müsste ich jetzt mal durchgucken, ob man da zwei Fenster für zwei Teams machen kann?
Single Window, ich dachte mal, das ist dann jeweils, na egal. Wie auch immer, wenn man jetzt bezahlt, dann wird es irgendwie happig, weil in dem Moment, wo man eben diese Restriktionen aufheben will, also die Anzahl der Integrations und Unlimited History, muss man halt bezahlen und wenn man dann bezahlt, dann wird es auch gleich so richtig teuer, weil man zahlt dann pro aktiven User pro Monat und das geht bei 6 Dollar los.
Das heißt 6,67 Dollar.
Ja, 6,67 Dollar, sagen wir mal 7.
Noch so eine bescheute Sache in der deutschen Sprache. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Schau dir mal die französischen Zahlen an.
Das sollen wir erst mal ändern, soll 60, 7 heißen oder 60 und 7.
Schau dir mal die französischen Zahlen an.
Da wäre ich dann eine Woche üben müsste, bis ich wieder zählen kann, aber da wäre ich sofort dahinter. Das ist echt noch, das geht gar nicht.
Ich sag nur Catre-Van-Dues.
Ja, die Franzosen haben die Schicht.
Catre-Van-Dies-Neuf.
Genau, viel besser.
Die Verloren.
Naja.
Wahrscheinlich gibt es auch keine französischen Mathematiker, oder? Weil die mussten so viel...
Doch, gab's schon französische Mathematiker. Macht dir mal nix vor.
Aber ich glaube keine Zahlentheorie.
Ja, das ist nicht einfach.
Könnten wir den Alltagsrassismus zurückstellen?
Jetzt wo es Spaß macht.
Das hab ich vergessen, was ich sagen wollte. Die Preise, die Preise, die Preise. Das heißt, in unserem Fall, wie viel sind wir jetzt gerade hier bei Pottlove, hätten wir ein, zwei, ne, warte mal, eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs, sieben Leute drin. Sieben mal sieben Dollar wären 49 Dollar im Monat, um irgendwie diese Kommunikation aufrecht zu halten. Dass wir natürlich so einen gewissen Rahmen sprengen. Ich sehe ein, dass das jetzt für eine Firma durchaus noch skaliert, weil das ja auch ein wertvolles Tool ist, finde ich. Also vielleicht nicht für jeden, aber kann. Es gibt jetzt einen NGO-Tarif, wenn man eine registrierte NGO ist, dann kriegt man das wohl immer noch.
Was ist denn eine registrierte NGO?
Na, Wikimedia wäre zum Beispiel eine registrierte NGO, die jetzt wirklich irgendwie einen Eintrag hat, als wir sind jetzt hier. Als EV. EV und tralala, du kannst halt den gegenüber klar machen, du bist hier irgendwie, du arbeitest für das Gute. Und wenn, keine Ahnung, Greenpeace, irgendwas, du bist halt so eine NGO und du willst halt irgendwie dit haben und dann kriegst du halt deine Unlimited History auch so. Und weiß nicht ganz genau, welche Restriktionen dann noch gelten. Auf jeden Fall gibt es so einen Tarif. Was es leider noch nicht gibt, ist so ein Tarif für Open Source-Projekte. Weil das qualiert das halt einfach irgendwie nicht. Du willst halt schon, ich weiß nicht, dieses Unlimited History, das ist halt, könnte man vielleicht noch am ehesten darauf verzichten, obwohl es eigentlich geil ist. Und du willst aber auf jeden Fall möglichst viele von den Integration haben, weil die sind cool. Das ist einfach geiles Spielzeug. So oder so, es müsste noch irgendwas dazwischen geben. Also ich wäre zum Beispiel auch vollkommen okay mit irgendwas sowas wie ein Dollar pro User. Du kannst aber auch Gäste reinholen. Es gibt so ein explizites Hinzufügen von Gästen, die dann auch nur auf bestimmte Channels einen Zugriff haben, was ich ganz cool finde. Das heißt, wenn du mal jemanden einladen willst, mit dem Team zu diskutieren, ohne dass die gleich überall mitlesen und mitschreiben können, dann kannst du die quasi in so einen einzelnen Channel einsperren und sagen, hier ist so ein Gastkanal, so ein Boulevard der offenen Begegnung. Das kann man machen. Hab ich noch nicht mit rumgespielt, gibt es aber. Und Private Groups kannst du auch noch machen. Hab ich jetzt noch nicht so viel mit rumgespielt.
Ja, Private Groups ist wie ein normaler Channel, nur dass sich halt sonst keiner drauf connecten kann.
Was auch noch sehr schön ist, wenn du gegenüber so einem normalen Chat einen echten Vorteil hast, kannst du einfach so Bilder reinpasten. Die erscheinen dann so im Chat, so wie man das von iMessage kennt. Und du kannst dann aber die Bilder auch gleich kommentieren. Das ist sehr schön, wenn du zum Beispiel so Screenshots hast. Und hier, ich hab mal einen Screenshot und einen Mock abgemacht, sag mal was dazu. Und dann kannst du eben wirklich die Kommentare an dieses Bild ranhängen und den eigentlichen Diskussionskanal davon ein bisschen frei halten. Insofern, dass dann auch alle machen, was leider noch nicht geht, ist Video. Also wenn du jetzt so ein Video da reindropsst, dann kriegst du nicht gleich einen Player, was ein bisschen blöd ist. Also nicht nur jetzt mit YouTube gehostet, sondern auch wenn ich so ein mp4 hoch...
Aber ich glaube, du kannst das Video-File selber schon reindroppen, ne?
Du kannst es reindroppen, aber dann kannst du es nur runterladen, um es selbst zu schauen. Du hast ja nicht so ein inline Video-Player. Ich schätze mal, das ist etwas, was irgendwann nochmal kommen wird. Weil gerade wenn du jetzt so Screencasts machst, um irgendetwas zu erklären, wäre das halt mega praktisch, wenn man einfach sagen kann, ja hier, ich hab mal einen Screencast gemacht, drop den mal rein, dann wird der bei Slack gehostet und dann zeigen sie es dir im Chat halt auch gleich mit einem Player an, weil wo ist der Unterschied? Also ob ich jetzt ein Download mache oder mir das Ding direkt abspiele, während ich es lade, das kann ihnen ja eigentlich herzlich egal sein. Noch irgendwas vergessen? Also mir gefällt das und wer so Arbeitsgruppen hat, die so ein Kommunikationsproblem haben, soll sich das ruhig mal anschauen.
Die Emoticons sind schöner bei Skype.
Kannst du noch Sachen löschen, immer diese Witzbeiträge?
Du kannst alles editieren, kannst alle deine Chat-Einträge bearbeiten, kannst löschen.
Man kann sich ein bisschen aufräumen, ein bisschen kondensen, die wichtigen Sachen, den Rest noch ein bisschen entfernen, auch dieses ganze Hallo und Blabla und so alles raus.
Hier fragt einer im Chat, ob die Chats und History bei Slack liegen?
Ja klar, das ist jetzt voll cloud, ist voll hosted und so weiter. Natürlich ist das so.
Oder fand das einer mit den Franzosen nicht witzig?
Gleich mehrere französische Mannschaften. Ja, das sind doch mehrere. Foyer hat er jetzt nicht.
Wo wären wir ohne Foyer?
Irgendwann kam vorhin oder irgendwann vielleicht auch schon gestern.
Sind wir fertig mit Slack?
Da kam eine neue Streamer-Version raus gerade eben oder vorhin. Und da gab es ja so ein paar Leute, die hatten Probleme mit Streamer-Chats, die gingen dann einfach nicht mehr und das ist immer gecrashed oder wieder das Fenster zugegangen, wenn man mit bestimmten Leuten irgendwie chatten wollte. Das ist jetzt wohl gefixt. Also wer da irgendwie Sorgen hatte mit Streamer, der sollte sich das nochmal anschauen.
Sorgen hat mit Streamer.
Ja, da ging irgendwie was nicht. Also mich hat es nicht betroffen, aber Ahnenowohl.
Ich meine, dieser ganze Messenger-Markt ist ja nach wie vor heiß umkämpft.
Oh, iPad-compatible jetzt?
Ja, die haben jetzt auch mal ihr iPhone 6 Plus-Support gemacht und dabei iPad eingebaut. Das fällt quasi jetzt so zwangsläufig davon ab. Das war der kluge Schritt an diesem.
Ja, und der Admin kann jetzt aus einer Gruppe einzelne Leute entfernen. Das ging vorher auch nicht. Da waren nur rein, aber nicht raus, außer sie sind selber gegangen. Jetzt kann man Leute auch wieder rauskicken.
Wie FIFA irgendwann im Usenet sagte, oh ein Troll, findest du alleine raus oder sollen wir deinen Taxi rufen?
Ich habe noch nicht mal gezählt, wie viele Kanäle. Ich mittlerweile offen habe, um meine normale elektronische Kommunikation mit allen Leuten zu führen, mit denen ich sie gerne führen möchte. Ich glaube, ich bin so auf zehn gekommen.
Was ist denn alles ein Kanal? Jeder Irk-Channel ist ein Kanal?
Irk wäre dann sozusagen eins.
Den haben wir ja wohl alle, oder?
Ich weiß gar nicht mal, ob ich den zu dem Zeitpunkt so mitgezählt habe, weil Irk ist bei mir eher noch so ein Go-To-Medium, ehrlich zu sein.
Bei mir auch, aber immer mal wieder und immer öfter.
Ja, also zählen wir mal Irk mal ruhig mal mit.
Skype habe ich nicht.
Ich benutze auf jeden Fall iMessage, das ist wichtig. Trima, sehr, sehr selten, aber auch das ist so ein Kanal. Dieser Facebook-Messenger ist teilweise noch mit rein, aber sehr ungeliebt bei mir. Jetzt sind wir schon bei fünf.
Jumper hast du wahrscheinlich.
Ja, wobei es auch sehr abgehängt ist, muss ich sagen, bei mir.
Also nicht mehr so oft irgendwie meinst du? Ja, bei mir inzwischen auch, es ist gar nicht mehr so oft.
Jumper ist so gut wie tot.
Du bist ja gar nicht mehr online, ich so doch, doch, nur nicht da.
So, was hab ich noch?
Twitter.
Richtig, Twitter.
Ja, hab ich auch.
Ja, so Twitter, DMs und so weiter, das ist nicht ganz...
Nee, DMs nicht, mach ich gar nicht.
Doch, ab und zu.
Ja, doch, definitiv bei mir auch.
Fotostream.
Ich hab sogar BBM noch offen.
Ich hab Fotostream.
Ja, genau, einen Blackberry-Kontakt.
Ich hab mit ein paar Leuten...
Dann kommt Slack jetzt noch mit dazu.
Mit ein paar Leuten hab ich über Fotostream so eine Gruppe, wo wir immer Fotos rein posten.
Leute schreiben einen über WhatsApp an. Das ist das Gegenteil von GoTo Medium. Das ist so ein Medium...
Go weg.
Come to me.
Ja, das Blöde ist halt einfach echt, dass bestimmte Leute, vor allen Dingen die nicht so computerfine, die haben, wenn, dann haben sie WhatsApp.
So, jetzt bin ich schon bei zehn. Es waren bestimmt noch...
app.net hast du bestimmt vergessen.
Ja, app.net hab ich tatsächlich auch noch.
E-Mail.
Spielt aber auch zunehmend keine Rolle mehr. Ich glaub mit app.net ist bald vorbei.
E-Mail muss man dazu zählen, na klar. Richtig. 13.
Gibt ja immer noch Leute, die...
Ja, gibt's. Ist schwierig, aber es geht noch.
Gehört jetzt normales Telefon auch dazu?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Ich zähl das nicht so sehr unter elektronische Kommunikation.
Na gut.
Also es sind... Ich bin jetzt bei acht. Ich bin bei 13. Hab ich noch irgendwas vergessen?
Na ja, reicht ja auch, ne?
Ja, dann gibt's hier noch diesen privaten SSH-basierten Kanal. Der ist auch mehr so Go-To-Medium, aber...
Sehr lame.
Ja, Mosch funktioniert bei mir irgendwie nicht.
Na, gibt's da noch einen richtigen Client?
Wie, was gibt ein Client für einen Mac?
Für alle Unixe. Echt? Aber ich bin auch SSH.
Ja, aber Mosch ist trotzdem irgendwie... Der braucht dann irgendwelche ganz abstrusen Ports, die offen sein müssen. Und dann funktioniert's irgendwie in der Regel ja doch nicht.
Aber was für eine Welt, ja? Also ich habe 13 Endpoints.
Ja, aber das ist doch genau das, was wir wollen. Dezentralität, Diversifikation, nicht alles auf einer Plattform. Hast du doch gerade deine Eingangsrede, dein Eingangsplädoyer, hast du genau gedacht. Dass dich nicht alles verweilt.
Aber lokal bräuchte man jetzt einen Tool, der alles in einer App zusammenfasst.
Genau, Single-Inbox, so. Weil ich weiß dann immer, Hauptproblem ist, habe ich irgendwie alles überhaupt richtig konfiguriert, bin ich gerade über alles erreichbar. Jetzt kam ich zum Beispiel gerade aus England und ich muss dann immer SIM-Karten hin und her stecken.
Jetzt hast du mal ein iPhone mit Dual-SIM gekauft.
Hätte ich mal, habe ich aber nicht. Ich stecke dir dann um, weil ich habe festgestellt, mit deutscher SIM-Karte in England einfach nicht genug Daten. Einfach Daten ist das Problem. Hätte ich da irgendwie meine 5 GB, dann wäre alles super, aber das geht ja aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht, weil Europa ist ja nicht Europa. Wie auch immer. Und dann stecke ich also hier die SIM-Karte rein. Dann habe ich Leute per iMessage erreicht. Dann habe ich dann wieder gemerkt, dass ich Leute kenne, die kein iPhone haben. Denen musste ich dann eine SMS schicken.
Ja, diesen Moment.
Die haben sich dann irgendwie nicht gemeldet. Später habe ich dann festgestellt, als ich so ein bisschen an meinem Telefon irgendwie versucht habe, irgendwas zu konfigurieren, eine Message, gab es dann so bei iMessage so einen Anschalter, da stand irgendwie Waiting for Activation. Hab ich gemerkt, irgendwas hat sich da nicht aktiviert und auf einmal war auch meine deutsche Rufnummer nicht in Messages drin. Genau, ich habe nämlich versucht, mein Telefon mit meinem Computer, mit Yosemite zu verbinden, damit ich die SMS nicht an meinem Telefon tippen muss, weil ich hasse Nachrichtentippen irgendwie, wenn ich auch einen Computer mit einer Tastatur da stehen habe, dann will ich das machen und diese neue Integration ist eigentlich eine tolle Sache. Dann wollte ich halt mein Telefon mit dem Computer perren, damit ich meine SMS auf dem Rechner schreiben kann und das funktionierte nicht und ich kotzte und wusste nicht, warum es nicht geht.
Das ist immer out of sync und wenn er dann synkt, dann hat das anscheinend der Algorithmus so, dass er einen Gesprächspartner, den synkt er dir dann rein, aber die andere Seite nicht, das heißt, der unterteilt es noch, also das geht alles gar nicht.
Wenn ich meine richtige Tastatur benutzen kann, um eine SMS zu schreiben, dann ist mir schon geholfen. Aber es hat irgendwie nicht funktioniert. Es kam irgendwie dieser Code nicht hoch und ich wusste nicht warum. Dann habe ich irgendwann ein bisschen rumgeguckt, habe festgestellt, dass in meinem iMessage-Setting, iMessage war an, aber da stand irgendwie Waiting for Activation oder kann nicht aktivieren. Ich so, wieso, was, was, was ist das denn jetzt? Ausgeschaltet, eingeschaltet, Waiting for Activation. Guckte, Internets, was kann das sein? Ja, hier, mach mal dies, schalte mal noch mal aus, schalte noch mal an, geht nicht, Reboote mal, ja, alles gemacht und so. Apple, offizielle Support-Seite, alles gemacht. Und dann irgendwann kam, ruft deinen Telefon-Provider an und fragt an, ob du irgendwie SMS kriegst. Und ich so, ah, Activation SMS. Was ich nicht realisiert hatte, ist, dass wenn ich jetzt iMessage einschalte auf meinem iPhone, dass vermutlich zur Authentifizierung im Hintergrund quasi eine SMS an dieses Telefon geschickt wird, wodurch diese Authentifizierung automatisch abläuft. Das heißt, im iOS ist so eine Funktionalität drin, dass wenn ich iMessage einschalte, er dem Telefon eine SMS schickt. Und wenn diese SMS kommt, dann ist quasi bestätigt, dass diese Rufnummer auch stimmt. Ich hatte aber durch meine permanenten SIM-Kartenwechsel in meiner O2-Konfiguration mich irgendwie mittlerweile so weit verdaddelt, dass die SMS an ein anderes Gerät mit einer zweiten SIM-Karte ging, was aber in England liegt. Und dann musste ich also erst meine Konfiguration umstellen und dann funktionierte das wieder. Sodass dann überhaupt erst SMS-Empfang wieder anfing und ich dann auch merkte, warum die ganzen Leute nicht geantwortet haben. Die haben mir sehr wohl geantwortet. Das hat mich bloß auf meinem Telefon nicht erreicht. Und das ist so dieses andere Problem. Weil jetzt hab ich ja so 13 Kanäle, die ich eigentlich offen halten muss. Ich muss die ganze Zeit auch irgendwie sicherstellen, dass ich überall online bin. Dass wenn ich darüber eine Nachricht bekomme, die ja potenziell wichtig sein kann, weil Leute sich darauf verlassen, dass sie mich darüber erreichen können, dass ich die dann auch wirklich bekomme. Und dann natürlich dieses klassische Problem, worüber habe ich diese Nachricht bekommen? Das ist das Schlimmste. Ich weiß, dass ich diese Informationen gesehen habe, aber ich hab keine Ahnung mehr, war das jetzt über Facebook, war das eine SMS, war das iMessage, kam das über ADN, war das eine Twitter-DN, war das eine E-Mail und so weiter. Und ich merke auch immer wieder, wenn ich sage, du willst mir verlässlich eine Nachricht zukommen lassen, an die ich mich potenziell auch vier Wochen später noch dran erinnere, dann gibt es eigentlich immer nur noch einen einzigen Dienst, der irgendwie funktioniert, das ist Mail. Weil das ist auch das Einzige ist, wonach man suchen kann. Das ist nicht so flüchtig.
Ja, E-Mail hat was, bestehen nichts.
Ja, aber E-Mail ist auch bis heute der rotzigste Job von allen.
Deswegen vielleicht.
Verschlüsselung funktioniert da nicht ordentlich.
Aber es ist ehrlich, weil Verschlüsselung woanders auch eigentlich nicht ordentlich funktioniert.
Bei einem ist es schon.
Die gute Blackbox-Krypto.
Das ist die Nachrichten-Konfusion.
Sie baden gerade ihre Hände drin. Und dann, wenn du es nicht mal, wenn du es dann auch, was ja noch ein Teil ist, wenn du Kleins auf mehreren Plattformen hast und die dann nicht sinken, das ist dann auch noch Teil 3 des Desasters der Multikanal-Kommunikation.
Ja, wie sieht es denn aus? Ich glaube, die Sendung ist durch, oder? Wir haben wieder unsere vier Stunden.
Ja, das mit meinem Entschleunigungsthema, das hebe ich mir dann fürs nächste Mal auf.
Ja, eigentlich gibt es auch vom Umzug nicht mehr zu erzählen, außer dem, dass sich ein paar lustige kurdische Umzugs...
Nächstes Mal haben wir ja alle unsere Apple Watch und unser neues MacBook.
Ach, die nächste Sendung ist erst in sechs Wochen.
Ich weiß gerade noch gar nicht, wann die nächste Sendung ist. Ja, mal gucken. Also das hängt so ein bisschen davon ab. Jetzt ist ja erstmal Potlap Workshop, dann ist Republika, Dennis Lieblingsveranstaltung. Und dann wäre theoretisch in zwei Wochen was, aber da ist es sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass ich hier bin. Deswegen wird es da wahrscheinlich nichts geben.
Also der Tag vor Christi Himmelfahrt?
Der wird es nicht werden. Und dann wird es der danach wahrscheinlich auch nicht werden.
Da ist er aber eingetragen.
Ja, der 20.
ist eingetragen. Behauptet mein Kalender.
Ja, du hast recht.
Wir sollen ja nicht so viel über Kalender reden, aber mein Kalender sagt...
Okay, ich kann es noch nicht sicher sagen. Es ist alles gerade etwas schwierig.
Also wenn der Termin nicht klappt, dann ist die Watch wahrscheinlich da.
Ja, muss ich später noch nachreichen. Wer die Sendung gerne live hört, guckt mal auf freakshow.fm.de Da ist der Kalender, den kann man abonnieren. Dann wisst ihr es immer genau.
Ja, vielleicht funktioniert auch der Stream.
Ansonsten schaut bei der Hörsuppe vorbei, die merkt sich das ja auch immer ganz gut. Und wir werden das auch noch ver-tweeteren und so. Es bleibt jetzt noch ein bisschen ruppig, hier mit dem Metaebene-Schedule bis Ende Juli. Und dann ist August, dann ist es auch nochmal ruppig.
Im Sommer ist doch eh Sommerloch hier.
Echt, so lange ist noch hier ruppig.
Ja, bis Ende Juli. So lange muss ich da noch absitzen.
Aber ist ja gut, weil ich bin ja dann noch im Juli segeln wieder. Schon wieder?
Aber alles wird gut. Und dann ist Camp und auf dem Camp machen wir sicherlich irgendwie eine nette Show, oder?
Wenn die Leute uns bis dahin nicht vergessen haben.
Wenn sie sich wieder auf die Treppen vollstellen und so.
Auf dem Camp machen wir was und spätestens absitzen wir. Es gibt keine Treppen auf dem Camp, oder? Ist Regelbetrieb hier und dann machen wir irgendwie jede Woche, oder? Oder jeden Tag.
Wir machen hier gleich unsere Betten hier und machen eine Woche Dauer-Live-Sendung. Mit Dauerbesuch dann aber auch, damit Action ist.
Genau.
Ja, dann können wir die Themen mal richtig durchrocknen, nicht gleich wieder abbrechen.
Drei Stunden Fritzbox. Warum nur drei, warum nicht sechs?
Ja, also liebe Hörer, vielen Dank für euer Interesse und fortgesetzte Unterstützung und all das. Belast es dabei, alle klugen Kommentare bitte ins Blog unter freakshow.fm. Da auch bitte die Flatterklicks ablassen und die sonstigen Bitcoins und Beschenkungen und so weiter. Wie gesagt, bitte in diesem Sommer hier noch keine Verschickungen machen, keine Pakete, die führen nur ins Nirvana und sonst nirgends wohin.
Ja, fertig.
Wie du hast jetzt England als Nirvana bezeichnet.
Vielen Dank noch weiterhin für die Spenden, die sozusagen noch weiter ankommen, über Amazon und so weiter.
Genau.
Ja, stimmt.
Und ansonsten geht man ins Friedel Richter und schaut euch das Flip-Dot-Display an und es ist ein Steak, das ist lecker. Genau.
Oder Piripiri Hühnchen, das ist auch lecker.
Piripiri Hühnchen.
Genau.
Und die rosa Fritten.
Aber der Kartoffelbrei, der ist auch super.
Stimmt.
Mit Erdfüllen drin und so.
Ich lad euch hier jedes Mal ein, mein Freund.
Was eigentlich mit den Flatter-Hits bei der letzten Sendung, da passiert irgendwie gar nichts. Deine Seite oder die andere Seite?
Unsere Seite.
Das wird teuer für dich.
Wir sagen Tschüss.